ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BACKER
FORGES CABALLERO CORTES THREE
DALLY DODD TORONTO EGGMAN GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG WITHOUT
HER TADO JONES KAMLAGER LAYERED
LEYVA LIMÓN MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN
. NEWMAN NIELSEN A SHOW OF HANDS
PORTANTINO OFF RUBIO SKINNER
STERN AMBERG WHY CASKEY WIENER
WELL. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. I'D LIKE TO ASK ALL OF
OUR MEMBERS TO MOVE TO THEIR
SEATS ON THE FLOOR AND WHAT OUR
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BE ON THE
REAL AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY SENATOR RUBIO AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR JONES SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
CREATOR GOD BLESS AND AFFIRM OUR
BELONGING MAYOR BELONGING TO BE
A HEALING BALM. AND A SUPPORTIVE
HAND. MAYOR BELONGING BE AN
ENCOURAGING VOICE. MAY WE BE
FREE. ONE ANOTHER TO SPEAK THE
TRUTH AS WELL AS THE WORD THAT
RICE EASILY. MAY WE HELP ONE
ANOTHER TO CREATE THE ORDINARY.
AND THE GREAT. MAY WE
ACKNOWLEDGE WITH CHOI THE UNIQUE
F. THAT IS OUR BELONGING
BELONGING EMPOWER US TO REACH
BEYOND TO WELCOME IN SHELTER
OTHERS. MAYOR BELONGING FREE US
TO LIVE RADICALLY WITHIN THE
BROADER ARENA OF THE WORLD MAY
WE TREASURE THAT. THE COMPANIONS
OF THE PAST WHO SHAPED INSURED
OR BELONGING AS WE MOVE TOGETHER
AND TO THE FUTURE WITH HOPE WE
ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME AMEN. IT'S
TIME IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. HERE IS ALL THERE
IS. MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE
SENATORS BATES AND BRADFORD
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK ON AN ITEM PLEASE USE
THE RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ. MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES PURSUANT TO SENATE
RULE TWENTY NINE TEN SMALL D.
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB. FOUR EIGHTEEN. A
MOTION TO APPROVE THE SENATE
JOURNALS WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF
JANUARY TWENTY FOURTH THROUGH
TWENTY SEVEN WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON TO
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST READING
OF BILLS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL. 888-898-9890
ONE AND SENATE BILL EIGHT NINETY
TWO THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM EIGHT.
FILE NUMBER EIGHT IS
SENATOR LEYVA SPELL. THE THREE.
SENATE BILL FIFTY THREE BY
SENATOR LEYVA AN ACT RELATING TO
UNSOLICITED IMAGES CENTER LEYVA
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS SB FIFTY THREE ALSO
KNOWN AS THE FLASH ACT WILL SET
LEGAL PROTECTIONS FOR TECHNOLOGY
USERS WHEN THEY RECEIVE
UNSOLICITED SEXUALLY EXPLICIT
IMAGES AND VIDEOS BETTER KNOWN
AS CYBER FLASHING THE FLESH
AFTER CREATES A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION AGAINST ANY PERSON WHO
KNOWS OR REASONABLY SHOULD KNOW
THAT THE LEWD IMAGES TRANSMITTED
ARE UNSOLICITED. ACCORDING TO
THE PEW RESEARCH CENTER 53% OF
YOUNG AMERICAN WOMEN AND 33337%
OF YOUNG AMERICAN MEN HAVE BEEN
SENT UNSOLICITED EXPLICIT
MATERIAL WELL ONLINE ALSO THE
MAJORITY OF WOMEN WHO RECEIVED
UNPROMPTED SEXUALLY EXPLICIT
IMAGES REPORTED BEING SENT THIS
MATERIAL THROUGH VARIOUS SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS SUCH AS SNAPCHAT
INSTAGRAM LINKED IN TWITTER AND
FACEBOOK THIS BEHAVIOR ALSO
OCCURS VIA DATING PLATFORMS.
TEXT MESSAGES AND EMAILS. IN
SOME CASES UNSOLICITED SEXUALLY
EXPLICIT MATERIAL IS EVEN-
DROPPED IN PUBLIC SPACES TO
UNSUSPECTING RECIPIENTS. IF YOU
DON'T THINK IT'S HAPPENING L.
SOME OF YOUR YOUNGER STAFFERS
THEY WILL LET YOU KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING MEMBERS CYBER FLASHING
IS ABUSIVE AND IT IS WRONG NO
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD EVER BE SENT
A SEXUALLY EXPLICIT PICTURE OR
VIDEO WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT WHEN
IT HAPPENS IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HOLD THOSE PERPETRATORS
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR THEIR BEHAVIOR
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR WIENER. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RUNNING
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB. FIFTY THREE AND I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR- FOR REALLY
LISTENING TO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I AND OTHERS HAD
ABOUT SOME POTENTIAL. UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THE WAY THE BILL
WAS. DRAFTED AND OF THE AUTHOR
VERY GRACIOUSLY HIT THE PAUSE
BUTTON ON THE BILL TO MAKE IT TO
YOUR BILL- AND WORKED
DILIGENTLY- TO REALLY MAKE SURE
THIS IS GOING TO FOCUS ON THIS
REALLY. ABUSIVE KIND OF
SITUATION. WE'RE PEOPLE
HARASSING EACH OTHER BY SENDING
THESE PHOTOS IN A CONTEXT WHERE
NO ONE IS ASKING HIM- OR THERE'S
NO WAY THAT ANYONE COULD THINK
THAT THAT IS OKAY- SO THE REASON
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL I THINK
REALLY. FOCUS- TIÞN AND OPERA
AND I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THAT I.
SENATOR ROOM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I ALSO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL SB FIFTY
THREE AS A PROD CO AUTHOR I WANT
ALSO THINK THE CENTER OF THE
RETAINER FROM CHINO FOR TO DO
SEEN THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
SENDING UNSOLICITED UNWANTED
EXPLICIT PHOTOS TO ANOTHER
PERSON WHICH THE STATE IS THE
ACT OF CYBER FLASHING IS JUST
SIMPLY A MODERN WAY OF HARASSING
VICTIMS INTIMIDATING VICTIMS AND
THAT NEEDS TO STOP I ALSO HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF MEETING WITH.
THE SEAL BUMBLE WHICH IS A
DATING APP AND WE LEARNED THAT
THIS IS A REALLY- IT'S AN ISSUE
THAT CONTINUES TO HAPPEN MORE
AND MORE AND IF WE DON'T DO
SOMETHING TO STOP IT IT COULD
LEAD TO TWO OTHER CRIMES
ESPECIALLY ARGUES WHO ARE
CONSTANTLY BOMBARDED BY THESE
PREDATORS TRYING TO SEEK THEIR
ATTENTION SO I'M REALLY THANKFUL
THAT THIS HAS BEEN INTRODUCED
AND I THINK THAT YOU KNOW AS WE
PASS LAWS THESE PERPETRATORS
CONTINUE TO FIND YOU IN MORE
CREATIVE WAYS OF STOCKING
INTIMIDATING AND HARASSING. AND
SO ARE YOU REALLY DO NEED US TO
STAND STRONG AND STAND UP FOR
THIS BILL AND I ASKED
RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU. MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
FURTHER TO. OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SAYING MAN CENTER LABOR
YOU MAY CONCLUDE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU TO THE
MEMBERS WHO SPOKE IT WAS ALWAYS
MY INTENTION TO GET THE BILL TO
A POINT. THAT EVERYONE FEELS
COMFORTABLE WITH IT BUT WE CAN
STILL ACCOMPLISH OUR GOALS I'M
VERY GLAD THAT WE DID THAT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BAKER. I FOR JUST
HI CUT BY OTHER. I CORTES E. I
DALY. I DODD FIVE TORONTO HI
EGGMAN AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ
FIVE GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI WESA
FIVE PATADA I JONES I KAMLAGER.
I LAYERED HI LEYVA HI LIMÓN AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ. MAN I
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN AYE A SHOW OF
BOTH I CAN. HI PORTANTINO HI ROB
I RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER FIVE STERN
FIVE NUMBER WHITE HOUSE HE AYE
WIENER AYE WILK. FIVE SENATOR
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVEN
SENATOR ALAN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SIX
TWENTY BY SENATOR ALAN AN ACT
RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES.
CENTER ALAN. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS MEMBERS BOTH
IN STATE AND OUT OF STATE WINE
GROWERS HAVE BEEN ALLOWED TO
SELL AND SHIP. WINE DIRECTLY TO
CONSUMERS SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX CALIFORNIA HAS ALLOWED IN
STATE BREWERIES TO SHIP TO
CONSUMERS FOR SEVERAL DECADES.
IN ONE SERVICED SILVERLINE ING
OF THIS PANDEMIC HAS BEEN THE
DEVELOPMENT CREATIVE POLICY
IDEAS SPURRED BY THE NEED TO
ADJUST TO LIFE UNDER CODE
RESTRICTIONS IN MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY. HOW DOES THIS PEOPLE
WERE ADJUSTING TO LIFE WITH
WITH- IT WILL BE THE END OF THE
PANDEMIC IN THE NEED TO SPEND
LESS TIME IN INDOOR SPACES WITH
MANY OTHER PEOPLE ARE GOVERNOR
GOT A NEW SIM DIRECTED THE
DEPARTMENT ALCOHOL BEVERAGE
CONTROL TO ALLOW FOR DIRECT TO
CONSUMER. SHIPPING OF DISTILLED
SPIRITS AT THE THREE BOTTLES PER
DAY. THIS IS ONE OF SEVERAL
POLICIES PUT IN PLACE TO RESPOND
TO CONSUMER DEMAND IN THE
SOCIALLY DISTANT ECONOMY AND WAS
EXTENDED THROUGH THE END OF
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO JUST
BEFORE- IS DONE JUST BEFORE NEW
YEAR. TO HAVE THE STATE NOT
INTERVENED AND ALLOWED FOR
TEMPORARY ABILITY TO FOR DIRECT
TO CONSUMER. SHIPPING OF
DISTILLED SPIRITS MANY LOCAL
DISTILLERIES MAY HAVE BEEN
FORCED TO SHUT DOWN PERMANENTLY
. AND NOW WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SUPPORT THESE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES BY CREATING A BETTER
SYSTEM ALL WHILE INCREASING
ACCESS CONVENIENCE. AND SAFETY
FOR CUSTOMERS IN PROTECTING
WORKERS. SO THIS BILL SEEKS TO
EXPAND MARKET ACCESS FOR. FOR
DISTILLERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND
ENSURE CONSUMER ACCESS TO
SPECIALTY AND NICHE PRODUCTS NOT
FOUND IN STORES. WE HAVE SEEN
THE DIRECT TO CONSUMER MODEL
WORK VERY EFFECTIVELY IN THE
WINE AND BEER MARKETS. ARE AY
OTHER STATES. IN CALIFORNIA
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC AND WE
KNOW IT'S WHAT CONSUMERS WANT
AND WE ALSO KNOW. THAT IT
DOESN'T. HARM OTHER INDUSTRIES
THAT THAT WORK IN THE
DISTRIBUTION SPACE. THIS BILL
WENT INTO PRINT- ALMOST A YEAR
AGO MEMBERS. IT WAS THE SUBJECT
OF AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING. IN
NOVEMBER I FELT WE THE CHAIR OF
THE GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE ASKED US TO HOLD THE
BILL BACK TO GIVE IT SOME MORE
TIME. WE HAD A BIG INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. IN NOVEMBER. AND BASED
ON WHAT WE LEARNED DURING THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING WE LIMITED
THE QUANTITY DISTILLED SPIRITS
TO MIRROR. THE RULES THAT EXIST
IN IN IN CERTAIN STATES. I'VE
BEEN OPPOSITION CAME FORWARD
DURING THE SENATE G. O. WE NEED
FURTHER MEMBERS TO SIGNIFICANT
LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF SPIRITS IT
COULD BE SHIPPED. TO EACH
INDIVIDUAL WE FURTHER LIMITED-
WE LIMITED THE CRAFT DISTILLERS
IN THE AMOUNT THAT THEY COULD
SHIP FOR THE BIG GUYS ANY
DISTILLER MAKING MORE THAN A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND GALLONS
OF DISTILLED SPIRITS FOR YOUR
TOTAL ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD.
WOULD BE ONLY BE AUTHORIZED TO
SHIP UP TO EIGHT. OR NINE LITERS
PER YEAR THAT'S ABOUT A BOTTLE A
PER MONTH TO INDIVIDUALS. AS
PART OF A SUBSCRIPTION SERVICE.
THE TOTAL VOLUME THEY COULD SHIP
TO CONSUMERS EACH YEAR IN THE
STATE WOULD BE CAPPED. AT A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND GALLONS.
AND BY THE BY THE WAY MEMBERS
THAT'S- PER LICENSE. PER
DISTRIBUTOR LICENSE I'M SUPER
DISTILLER LICENSE SO THAT'S NOT
PRODUCT BY PRODUCT THAT'S THEIR
ENTIRE INVENTORY. FOR A BIG
DISTILLERY WE ALSO THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT I KNOW FOR A LOT OF
OUR MEMBERS. WE NEED TO MANAGE
TO ENSURE THAT ONLY COMMON
CARRIERS. SO WITH YEAH I THINK
UPS. DHL POSTAL SERVICE FEDEX. I
WOULD BE ALLOWED TO HANDLE THE
SHIPMENT OF THESE PRODUCTS.
THESE MEMBERS WERE ALL BASED ON
OPPOSITION CONCERNS REQUESTING
THAT WE FOCUS THE BILL AND
SUPPORTING CRAFT DISTILLERS. IN
REQUIRE THE SHIPMENTS OCCUR
THROUGH COMMON. CARRIERS I'VE
SPOKEN TO MANYOF YOU I KNOW-
THE CHAIRMAN DIED AS WELL. I
REMAIN COMMITTED TO WORKING TO
ADDRESS THE MAIN CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION DISTRIBUTORS. THAT
WHAT I GOTTA SAY IT'S BEEN VERY
VERY DIFFICULT. I'M HAPPY TO
OPERATE FURTHER- IF PEOPLE HAVE
QUESTIONS- BUT WE'RE TRYING TO
ALTERNATELY TO CREATE PARITY
WITHIN OUR CURRENT SYSTEM
SUPPORTING CRAFT DISTILLERS. AND
CONSUME- AND AN EXPANDING
CONSUMER ACCESS. AND IT'S IN
THAT SPIRIT THAT I RESPECT
RESTAURANT VOTE I KNOW THAT. ARE
THE JOINT AUTHORS- CHAIRMAN DODD
WANTED TO. THANK YOU CENTER
ALLEN MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SENATOR DODD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ABOUT A PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AS CHAIR AND GEO I
WANTED TO PROVIDE SOME
BACKGROUND ON SB SIX TWENTY
DISCUSS SOME OF OUR CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED. FIRST
DIRECT TO CONSUMER SHIPPING IS
NOTHING NEW THE WINE INDUSTRY
HAS FOR DECADES HAVE THE ABILITY
TO SHIP DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS IN
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE HAS BEEN
ABLE TO SHIP THE CONSUMERS AND
OTHER STATES AND VICE VERSA.
WITH NO RESTRICTIONS. NO BOTTLE
LIMITATIONS NO PRICE LIMITATIONS
NO NOTHING. IN ADDITION
CALIFORNIA BREWERIES REGARDLESS
OF SIZE ARE CURRENTLY ALLOWED TO
SHIP UNLIMITED AMOUNTS OF BEER
DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. NO I KNOW
THE PURE PORSCHE THIS BILL. IS
BEING REMOVED. WHEN HE COMES
BACK HERE FOR CONCURRENCE BEER
WILL NOT BE PART OF THIS. BILL
AND I WANT TO MAKE THAT CLEAR TO
EVERYBODY BECAUSE THE BEER
INDUSTRY HAS SEEN THEIR WAY FIT.
TO CONTINUE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
IN CALLING THE PEOPLE'S OFFICE
REALLY. FRANKLY CONFUSING THE-SITUATION BECAUSE BOTH THE
AUTHOR AND THAT I HAVE MADE IT
CLEAR THAT BEER IS NOT GOING TO
BE A PART OF THIS BILL. THIS IS
BEEN GOING YOUR WITH YOUR- I'M
JUST. CENTER ALLEN IS ALREADY
TALKED ABOUT THIS I DON'T WANT
TO REPEAT- I BRIEFLY WANT TO
SPEAK UP ON. THE ABOUT THE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WELL WIDE IF HAS
HAD THIS PRIVILEGE FOR DECADES.
DIRECT TO CONSUMER SALES IN THE
WINE INDUSTRY REPRESENTS LESS
THAN. 2% OF WINE SALES DIRECT TO
CONSUMERS LESS THAN 2% OF WINE
SALES. IN IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE
WHEN THAT WOULD THROUGH
EVERYBODY BECAME WILDLY
SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE THE MARKET
EXPANDED. AND PRODUCERS
RETAILERS AND DISTRIBUTORS ALIKE
WHO IS A RISING TIDE JERRY
EVERYBODY WENT OUT. IT'S SIMPLE
DIRECT TO CONSUMER SHIPPING
FRANKLY IS EXPENSIVE. THE
CONSUMER ALSO HAS TO WAIT FOR
DAYS IF NOT WEEKS FOR THE
PRODUCT TO ARRIVE WHAT IT DOES
ARRIVE THE CONSUMER SOMEBODY
OVER THE AGE TWENTY ONE HAS TO
BE. THERE FOR THE PRODUCT IT'S
JUST TOO CUMBERSOME COMPARED TO
GOING TO THE LOCAL STORE AND
PURCHASING THAT PRODUCT WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS EXCLUSIVE
PRODUCTS- IF YOU'LL ON THE
MARKET. THE TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
DIRECT TO CONSUMER AND OF COURSE
OF THE PRODUCTS NOT AVAILABLE AT
THE RETAILER IT GIVES THE
CONSUMER AND THIS IS WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT ITS CONSUMER CHOICE IT
GIVES THE CONSUMER THE ABILITY.
TO BUY SOMETHING THAT THEY WOULD
NOT OF NOT OTHERWISE HAVE ACCESS
TO IT LAST YEAR WHEN A FISH BY
EMPHASIZING A COUPLE THINGS-
THIS ENTAILS CENTER. WITH THE
SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES. HAS
WORKED BILL. ON THIS EVEN THOUGH
THE A LOT OF THE OPPOSITION.
TALK TO THE OLD SEND OUT. BLAST
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU SAYING
THAT HE READ IT OR HE HASN'T
CALLED OR ANYTHING I'VE BEEN
THERE FIRSTHAND WITH HIM WORKING
HARD. EVERY STEP OF THE WAY- WE
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS A
COMMITMENT TO MOVE THIS BILL
ALONG. SO THAT WE CAN MAKE IT A
BETTER BILL IN THE ASSEMBLY
BRING IT BACK OVER HERE WITH A
BILL THAT EVERYBODY. CAN GET
BEHIND I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU CENTER DODD SIMILARLY
MON. THANK YOU THE PRESIDENT I
RISE AS A CO AUTHOR OF S. B. S.
SIX TWENTY. IT'S A BILL THAT
SUPPORTS US SMALL CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES BY PROVIDING ACCESS
TO A WIDER MARKET PLACE AND
GIVING THEM MORE OPPORTUNITIES
TO TRY ESPECIALLY JUNE PANDEMIC.
IN MY DISTRICT I HAD THE CHANCE
TO VISIT SOME OF THESE
DISTILLERIES- WHERE PEOPLE
ACTUALLY GO FOR TASTING AND
WOULD LIKE TO PURCHASE-
SOMETHING AND WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT ONLINE AND SO-
IT'S BEEN IMPORTANT. AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR VERY SMALL
AND FAMILY RUN BUSINESSES- THAT
ARE PART OF OUR LOCAL ECONOMIES.
I AM VERY HAPPY TO HEAR- A FROM
THE- AUTHOR AND ALSO FROM OUR
CHAIRMAN GOP THAT THERE IS EVERY
INTENTION OF BRINGING BACK
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN WORK WITH
THAT I THINK THAT FOR MANY OF
US. WHO SUPPORT THIS BILL WE'RE
ALSO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT HOW WE
BRIDGE- SOME OF THIS DIVIDE THAT
WE WOULD THAT WE'VE SEEN IT WITH
OUR LEVER BROTHERS AND SISTERS
AND THAT WE AVOID SOME OF THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WHETHER
IT'S A SMALL DISTILLERIES IS
VERSUS THE BIG ONES OR WHETHER
IT'S THE TYPE OF ALCOHOL.
CERTAINLY THIS IS NOT EASY AND
GRATEFUL TO BOTH OF THE AUTHORS-
AND I'M VERY HOPEFUL THAT IN THE
NEXT ROUND IN THE NEXT
REITERATION OF THIS BILL WE WILL
SEE A BILL- THAT WILL HAVE A
HOPEFULLY LABOR NEUTRAL OR IN
SUPPORT OF THIS- AND SO WITH
THAT TODAY I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL AS A CO AUTHOR AND
LOOK FORWARD TO SOME RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR LIMÓN. SENATOR
ALSO. THANK YOU MAY PRESIDENT I
. AND I. TO SB SIX TWENTY. LARGE
OUT OF STATE DISTILLERY
BUSINESSES HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
PROBLEM GETTING THEIR PRODUCTS
TO MARKET. AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
THE LARGE DISTILLERS WOULD SELL
TO PUT CONSUMERS AND BYPASS THE
DISTRIBUTORS AND DELIVER UP TO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND GALLONS
OF THEIR PRODUCTS PER YEAR. THAT
TRANSLATES INTO HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF BOTTLES PER YEAR
DIRECT TO CONSUMER BY PASSING
GOOD JOBS UNDERMINING SALES AT
GROCERY STORES AND OTHER LOCAL
SMALL BUSINESSES. FOR THIS
REASON IT APPEARS TO BE ANOTHER
ATTEMPT TO DE REGULATE ALCOHOL
SALES I LIKE ALL THE REGULATION
EFFORTS IT IS BOUND TO BE
DISASTROUS FOR THE WORK FORCE. I
UNDERSTAND AN AMENDMENT WAS
PROPOSED WITH CRAFT DISTILLERS
THAT WOULD HAVE CREATED A DIRECT
TO CONSUMER PRIVILEGE FOR MOM
AND POP DISTILLERIES WITHOUT A
SOLUTION THAT PROTECTS GOOD
LOCAL JOBS AND LOCAL BUSINESSES
I WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR DORADO
SENATOR COLLAR. THANK YOU CENTER
ALAN. THANK YOU- KAMLAGER THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WILL-
UNFORTUNATELY BE LAYING OFF THIS
BILL TODAY- I APPLAUD THE AUTHOR
FOR. WOW ESERVERS INCREDIBLY
RIGHTEOUS ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS ALL
THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
COMING AT HIM FROM ALL SIDES
FOR- WEEKS NOW AND CERTAINLY
BELIEVE THAT WE WILL GET TO THE
FINISH LINE WITH SOMETHING THAT
MAKES SENSE FOR EVERYONE
ESPECIALLY OUR SMALL CRAFT
DISTILLERIES AND- ARE CONSUMERS
. BUT- I ACTUALLY RAISED
CONCERNS- NGO OUT WHEN THIS BILL
WAS HEARD- AND OFFERED A
COURTESY VOTE TO KEEP THE
DISCUSSIONS GOING AND HAVE BEEN
MONITORING THEM- AS THINGS HAVE
PROGRESSED YOU KNOW I- AND
CONCERN THAT THE BILL DOES NOT
INCLUDE COMMON CARRIER WITH
EMPLOYEES LANGUAGE AND I AM ALSO
DEEPLY CONCERNED THAT IT
CONTINUES TO HAVE- BIG
DISTILLERIES IN IT I KNOW THAT
THEY GOT A HAIR CUT BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT LARGE. ENTITIES AND
CORPORATIONS- EVEN WHEN THERE
ARE CAPS THERE ARE WAYS TO WORK
AROUND THE CAPS IT IS JUST TRUE
AND I HAD A REALLY HEARTFELT
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR WHO
TALKED TO ME ABOUT THE INTENT
BEHIND THIS BILL AND WHY IT IS
SO IMPORTANT TO SUPPORT SMALL
CRAFT DISTILLERIES. AND WHILE
THE HIGH TIDE RISES ALL BOATS-
IT IS ALSO TRUE THAT WHEN THAT
HAPPENS YOU KNOW MOST OF THE
BOUNTY GOES TO LARGER COMPANIES-
AND SO I WOULD PREFER IF WE
SEPARATE THIS IN HOUSE SOMETHING
THAT FOCUSES ON BG CRAFT
DISTILLERIES AND THEN HAVE
SOMETHING THAT FOCUSES ON SMALL
BUSINESSES BECAUSE SO OFTEN WE
SAY WE'RE DOING THIS FOR THE
LITTLE GUY WE'RE DOING THIS FOR
THE LITTLE GUY. AND THEN THE BIG
GUYS SEE AN OPPORTUNITY AND THEY
JUMP ON TO THE BANDWAGON AND
THEN AS A RESULT THERE ARE A LOT
OF CHANGES THAT HAPPEN. TO
ACCOMMODATE THOSE SIZED
INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE DIFFERENT
NEEDS AND DIFFERENT CHALLENGES
THAN OUR SMALL MOM AND POPS THAT
ARE OFTENTIMES STRUGGLING TO
SURVIVE AND I SURMISE BECAUSE I
HAVE TALKED TO SOME OF THEM
WOULD LIKE SOMETHING
pI AM DISTURBED THAT WE ARE
PAINTING YOU KNOW WORKERS%
AGAINST WORKERS AND SO THAT IS
ALSO WHY YOU KNOW I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THIS BILL HAVE DIFFERENT
LANGUAGE IN AND AROUND. COMMON
CARRIER WITH EMPLOYEES AND
BECAUSE I KNOW. I AM ALSO VERY
GRATEFUL TO HEAR THAT THE NEXT
TIME WE WILL SEE IT YOU KNOW
BEER WILL NOT BE IN THIS YOU
KNOW BEER AND WINE AND SPIRITS.
THEY'RE ALL DIFFERENT KIND OF
CONSTELLATIONS AND SO IT MIGHT
MAKE SENSE FOR US TO TRY TO YOU
KNOW ADDRESS THEM- DIFFERENTLY
SO I HAVE IMMENSE SUPPORT AND-
RESPECT FOR. THE AUTHOR IN A
SUPPORT HIM- IN HIS EFFORTS AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO BEING ABLE TO
VOTE FOR THIS WHEN IT COMES BACK
WHEN SOME OF THESE ISSUES HAVE
BEEN ADDRESSED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER CALL MARKER WILL NEXT
GO TO SENATOR DOLLY. SENATOR
DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS A GOOD TO BE BACK I
WANTED JUST TO DISABILITY AND-
BOTH OPPOSITION INNOCENT AND THE
SUPPORT OF- TALK TO ME IN DEPTH
AND- NO I WANTED TO SHARE SOME
MY THOUGHTS ON. SOMETHING TAT'S
NOT IN THE BILL'S NOT TALKED
ABOUT AT ALL AND THAT IS-
SOMEBODY REPRESENTS A LOT OF
SMALL. COMMUNITIES IN CITIES AND
WHERE WE'VE SEEN. THE ABILITY
FOR DIRECT MARKETING STRAIGHT TO
YOUR HOME. IN THIS CASE THIS
WOULD BE HAPPENING AS WELL. BUT
WE SEE WITH AMAZON WE SEE WITH
COSCO WE SEE WITH A LOT OF
RETAIL. DISTRIBUTORS AND THEN
THE TAX BASE. DOESN'T GET
COLLECTED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
THAT'S BEEN SOMETHING THAT- I
KNOW THE SENATOR- A GLAZER HAD
BEEN WORKING ON WE TALKED ABOUT
THAT LAST YEAR BUT- WHAT FUND
YOUR CITY IS SALES TAX. AND YOUR
SMALL TOWNS. THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND NOT SALES TAX
PROVIDES SERVICES IN THOSE
CITIES AND COMMUNITIES. FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR PARKS FOR ALL
THE THINGS THAT THOSE BASICALLY
CITIES REALLY RELY ON SALES TAX
MORE MEANING THE COUNTIES. HAVE
PROPERTY TAX AND SO I TALK TO
THE AUTHOR- AND I TALKED TO- THE
SENATOR DODD ABOUT THE ISSUES.
THAT ARE QUE I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
SO TODAY I AND I'M NOW BACK TO
THE BILL. THE WHAT'S IN THE
BILL- WE HAVE SMALL DISTRIBUTORS
WE HAVE LARGEST JANITORS IN. I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
SMALL- COMPANIES ARE MADE WHOLE
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF. ROOM
TO WORK ON THIS BILL. AND SO
TODAY I'M GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL
BUT I WANT TO GO ON RECORD THAT
IF IT DOESN'T COME BACK. WITH
THE AMENDMENTS IT NEEDS FROM THE
OTHER HOUSE- I WON'T BE
SUPPORTING IT THEN AN IDEA DOES
NEED SOME WORK BEFORE I'LL BE
ABLE TO- CONTINUES SUPPORT SO
FOR THOSE REASONS I. WILL LET
THE BILL I'LL BE VOTING AYE ON
THE BILL TODAY. THANK YOU CENTER
DOLLING MAKES WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO SEND OVER BRADFORD IS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO LEND MY VOICE TO THIS ISSUE
AND I WANT ALSO RECOGNIZE YOUR
GREAT WORK THAT. OUR GENDER
ALLEN AND SENATOR DODD IS DONE
ON THIS MEASURE BUT I TO HAVE.
GREAT CONCERNS AS A INDIVIDUAL
WHO HAVE. DISTRIBUTORS BREWERIES
AND- STILLER'S AND DISTRICT I'VE
GOT OPPORTUNITY HAVE A LOT OF
DIALOGUE REGARDING THIS ISSUE
AND THEY STILL EXPRESS A LOT OF
CONCERN HOW ARE WE- THIS BILL
STARTED OUT. OUR DÍAS THE BILL
TO HELP SMALL CRAFT. PRODUCTS IS
VITALLY IMPORTANT AND WE SAW THE
BENEFIT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER LAST YEAR THAT
HELPED MANY OF THESE BUSINESSES
TO KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN AND
PEOPLE EMPLOYED. BUT THIS BILL
IS WORKED INTO SOMETHING MORE
THAN THAT AND H. QUITE
CHALLENGING WHEN I HEAR FROM
THOSE ENTITIES ARE MY COMMUNITY
WHO WERE FEARFUL OF WHAT MIGHT
HAPPEN TO THEIR BOTH BUSINESS.
IF THE BIG GUYS ARE ALLOWED TO
PLAY AT THE DEGREE THAT THEY ARE
REGARDLESS OF WHAT AMOUNT THAT
IS RIGHT NOW SO OF THE- ARE NOT
ABLE TO PULL. BECAUSE OF MY-
REMO PURCHASE A TODAY I STILL TO
VOICE MY CONCERN. OF THE LEVEL
ONE READING AS YOU ARE. FOR THIS
AGAIN I DID A BILL A COUPLE
YEARS AGO TO HELP THE SMALL
BREWERIES- ENABLE TO SEE STILL
MORE PRODUCTS DIRECTLY SO I'M
TOTALLY ARE IN SUPPORT OF. WHAT
THIS BILL IS ATTENDING TO DO ARE
TEMPTING TO DO OUR SHOULD SAY
BUT RIGHT NOW WHAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US THIS FAR MORE THAN
THAT IT'S- IT'S OPENING UP A-
FLOODGATE TO ALLOW. THE BIG GUYS
ONLY TO GET BIGGER AND FOR THOSE
REASONS I JUST I'M NOT READY AND
I'M GONNA. HOPEFULLY AGAIN IF IT
GETS BACK TO OUR FLOOR IT'LL BE
A BILL THAT REALLY. THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD. CENTRE HER
TADO. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. USUALLY BILLS LIKE THIS I JUST
STAND UP AND USUALLY SUPPORT BUT
ON THIS ONE IN PARTICULAR I DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS AT JUST AFTER
DOING MY OWN RESEARCH I WANTED
TO EXPRESS BUT ALSO TO ASK OF
THE AUTHOR- A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FOR. YOU KNOW THIRTY
CURRENTLY WE HAVE GAPS IN FOOD
SERVICE AND- CENTER TOTALEMENT.
CENTER ALAOUI TAKE A QUESTION
THANK YOU FOR SEATS ENTERED HER
TADO. SO WE CURRENTLY HAVE GAPS
IN OUR FOOD SURVEILLANCE WHICH
BECOMES EVENTUALLY FOOD SAFETY
ISSUE. I KNOW THERE WASN'T A
STUDY THAT WAS CONDUCTED JUST
LAST YEAR AND TWENTY TWENTY
ACTUALLY THAT- THAT CAME OUT
THAT SET THE 470-006-0060
LEADERS OF FAKE WHISKY IN NINE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED LITERS OF
COUNTERFEIT ALCOHOL FOR THE
MANUFACTURING OF. FRAUDULENT
SPIRITS- IT SEEMS LIKE THE E. U.
HAS A LITTLE BIT OF A OF A
PROBLEM IN THIS AREA- IT. SOME
OF THE COUNTERFEIT ALCOHOL
PROBLEM THE ISSUE THE ISSUE HAS
BEEN FACING. INCLUDES UP TO
TWENTY TWO DIFFERENT COUNTRIES.
AND SO MY QUESTION THE AUTHOR IS
WHAT REGULATORY PROTECTIONS ARE
IN PLACE TO PROTECT CONSUMERS
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHEN IT COMES TO FIX THE
EXPANSION. PLEASE PROCEED CENTER
ALAN YEAH I THINK THE CHAIRMAN
COULD PROBABLY SPEAK A LITTLE
MORE ABOUT THIS BECAUSE THERE
WERE SOME THERE WERE SOME
LANGUAGE THAT- THAT WAS WORKED
ON WITH GEO BUT- I'M I MEAN THE
END OF THE DAY- THAT. WE'VE NOT
SEEN THIS PROBLEM- IN OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE DONE THIS- I'M
HAPPY TO LOOK AT AND LANGUAGE IF
YOU REALLY WANT TO TIGHTEN IT UP
FURTHER ON ON ON THIS WHOLE
QUESTION OF COUNTERFEIT- BUT-
IT- I WERE TOTALLY TOTALLY
CENTER WHAT. HOW EXACTLY HAS
THIS PROBLEM. MANAGEMENT AS A.
SEVENTY YEAR THE IMMINENT EVEN
ALLUDING TO. PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU. IT JUST SEEMS TO ME
LIKE THIS IS IT THIS IS FOOD
FOOD SAFETY. IS AN AREA WHERE WE
DON'T REALLY PAY MUCH ATTENTION
TO BUT IT'S BECOMING MORE AND
MORE OF AN ISSUE. AND SO WHEN
YOU. OPEN UP THE MARKET WHICH IS
ON THE I DON'T THINK IT'S
NECESSARILY A BAD THING. I WOULD
STILL WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE FRAMEWORK IN PLACE SO
THAT WERE PROTECTING CONSUMERS
AND THAT THERE. ISN'T ANY A
COUNTERFEIT- I MEAN THE TRUTH IS
THAT NOBODY COULD SELL IF YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A OF A LICENSE TO
SELL THROUGH THE MECHANISM ON
THIS BILL AND ANYBODY WHO
ENGAGES IN A KIND OF FRAUDULENT
BEHAVIOR YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
WOULD GET. DING DID CERTAINLY
NOT ONLY WOULD THEY HAVE THEIR
LICENSE REVOKED I MEAN MAYBE A
FOR CRIMINAL CHARGES. AND SO I
AS I SAY YOU KNOW IF THERE'S IF
THERE'S SOME LANGUAGE WE CAN
TAKE TO. FURTHER UNDERSCORE THAT
I'M I'M HAPPY TO- TOOK TOOK TO
LOOK AT IT THIS IS WHAT A. B. C.
DOES ALL THE TIME I MEAN IT YEAH
THEY THEY THEY THEY WILL COME
DOWN LIKE A TON OF BRICKS ON
ANYBODY WHO. ENGAGES IN THE KIND
OF BEHAVIOR THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT. I'M NOT SURE IF THE
CHAIR. WOULD LIKE TO LIVE. THE
SENATE REGARDED YOU ALSO RESPOND
AS A CO AUTHOR. YES JUST. JUST
QUICKLY. COUNTERFEIT ALCOHOL
SALES ARE ILLEGAL. IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ANYWHERE IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. HE
SAID- YEAH THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS WE'VE BEEN TALKING TO.
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION- ON THIS
IS. YOU KNOW HOW DO WE- GET TO
THE POINT THAT WE CAN. MAKE THIS
WE'VE NEVER ADDRESSED THAT ISSUE
BECAUSE THAT IS IT'S CLEARLY
ILLEGAL. BUT ANYBODY THAT SHIPS
IN THE INTO THE IN YOU KNOW IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I THINK
TO BE A PERMIT PROCESS IS WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. SO THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE. WHICH
IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO EVERYBODY
IN THIS ROOM. NO ONE
UNDERSTANDS- SHIPPING. INTO THE
STATE. AND FINALLY. ANYBODY THAT
WITH THEIR INTENTIONS THEY WOULD
BE KNOWN BY. THE CALIFORNIA- EBC
. THANK YOU SENATOR DODD SENATOR
HER TADO DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. NOT AT THE MOMENT I
JUST AT MY CLOSET AT LIKE TO SAY
THAT WE HAVE SEEN AT LEAST FROM
MY UNDERSTANDING THROUGH THE FTA
THAT THERE ARE LETTERS THAT HAVE
GONE OUT WHERE THERE'S SOME.
SITUATIONS THAT ARE JUST NOT
NECESSARILY- TRANSPARENT WHERE
THERE'S CONCERN OF ABUSE IN OUR
FOOD SAFETY SYSTEM AND SO I
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'LL
CONTINUE TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
AND I'M HOPING THAT. THE AUTHORS
WILL MAKE THE NECESSARY CHANGES
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE PROTECT OUR
CALIFORNIANS OBVIOUSLY COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH YOUR OFFICE AND
WITH THE SENATOR- BECAUSE
THERE'S- THE LAST THING WE WANT
TO DO IS TO DO ANYTHING IN THIS
BILL THAT WOULD- WHICH WOULD
HARM PUBLIC SAFETY FOOD SAFETY.
THANK YOU CENTER TITLES THANK
YOU SENATOR ALAN CENTER SKINNER
. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- I
WAS IN A SITUATION LAST WEEK
BRYCE PRESENTING A BILL. WHICH
HAD SOME PROBLEMS THAT NEEDED TO
WORK OUT AND DIE. WHEN MY
PRESENTATION. AND ASKED FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TO MOVE THE BILL TO
ENABLE ME TO DO THAT AND I
ARTICULATED WHAT WE WOULD BE
DOING. IN THIS WE HAVE A
SITUATION HERE WHERE THERE ARE
STILL SOME THINGS TO BE WORKED
OUT- THE- THE COMIC CARE YOUR
ISSUE IS OBVIOUSLY ONE OF THEM.
AND I'VE HEARD A COMMITMENT ON
THAT. AND SO I FEEL THAT THE
NUMBER ONE. THE SMALL DISTILLERS
DEFINITELY NEED TO BE SUPPORTED
TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS TYPE OF
DIRECT CONSUMER SALE ANY OTHER
ISSUE AS MUCH AS I. REALLY HAVE.
BEEN VERY UNHAPPY THAT WE THAT
AS A SOCIETY IS COMMERCE HAS
MOVED TO SO SIGNIFICANTLY ONLINE
SALES AND WE'VE SEEN BRICK AND
MORTAR. INFECTED DYING AND WE
BUT WHEN WE THINK ABOUT LIKE
MANY OF OUR LAND USE POLICIES
ARE BASED AROUND BRICK AND
MORTAR OR SALES TAX POLICY SO
MUCH. AND YET THE REALITY IS
THAT THINGS ARE MOVING AWAY FROM
THAT SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
RE THINK SO MUCH IN ORDER TO
BRING BACK THE KIND EQUITY THAT
ALL OF US HAVE IN MIND FOR OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR OUR
RETAILERS FOR EVERYONE. IT FOR
CONSUMER PROTECTION BUT I DON'T
THINK TO PUT THAT ON THIS BILL
LOAN I THINK IS SOMEWHAT IS
UNFAIR BUT I AM GOING TO DO
THAT. LEAPOF FAITH THAT THE
AUTHOR AND THE VARIOUS PLAYERS
INVOLVED IN THIS BILL WILL
NEGOTIATE IN GOOD FAITH AND WILL
BRING US BACK SOMETHING THAT
PEOPLE FEEL BETTER ABOUT WITHOUT
I WILL VOTE ON. THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT OF WILL MEMBERS
FIRST OF ALL I'M VERY CLEAR THAT
THIS BILL STARTED OFF WITH MANY
DEFICIENCIES I THINK RECALL ALL
AGREE ON THAT AND BECAUSE OF
THAT I WASN'T AND FAVOR OF THIS
BILL AND I. STARTED OUT WORKING
WITH SOME OF OUR LABOR FRIENDS
TRYING TO ENSURE THAT WE FOCUS
ON SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT THEY
CARED ABOUT AND I WOULD JUST SAY
SPEAK FOR MYSELF BASED ON THE
MANY MANY HOURS I SPENT AT THE
AUTHOR HE CAN ATTEST IT IS NOT
ONLY EVENING WEEKENDS WE WERE ON
THE PHONE ALL THE TIME. I FELT
THAT I AT LEAST WHAT WAS ABLE TO
GET SOME OF THE LARGER ITEMS
THAT THEY WERE CONCERNED WITH
TOM AND AT NO TIME DID I HEAR NO
EVERY TIME I PRESENTED SOMETHING
THAT LABOR WANTED HE WOULD BE
AGREEABLE TO- UNFORTUNATE SOME
POINT THEY OPTED TO DIRECTLY
NEGOTIATE WITH THE AUTHOR OR NOT
SO QUE- BUT AS- I SAW IT THERE
IS A LOT OF WILLINGNESS TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THESE
ISSUES. I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
INDICATING CONTENT AGREEMENT BUT
I'M COMFORTABLE AND CONFIDENT
BASED ON ALL THE HOURS WE SPENT
ON THIS AND SEE HOW MUCH WE'VE
MOVED THE NEEDLE THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY IS THERE TO MAKE
THIS BILL REID AND CELL WITH
THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR. RUBIO CENTER NIELSEN.
BETTER PRESENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN SENATE. OVER THE YEARS
I'VE BEEN A LOT OF THESE.
CONTROVERSIAL OR HEAVILY DEBATED
HEAVILY AMENDED BILLS. BUT I'VE
LEARNED TO BE WARY. NOT AS MUCH
ABOUT TODAY. S. TOMORROW AND
NEXT YEAR. AND WAY IT OFTEN GOES
. TURTON COMPROMISING AMENDMENTS
ARE TAKEN. TO SECURE SUPPORT FOR
TODAY. AND THE BILL PASSES. GOES
INTO LAW. AND THEN IT SEALED
IMAGE AND TAKE A MILE NEXT YEAR
WE COME BACK WITH A WHOLE NEW
ARRAY OF ARGUMENTS. TO EXPAND
THE SCOPE AND SOME ONE PARTY OR
ANOTHER MAY WANT TO BE. DOES
THAT SAY THAT THERE IS A LACK OF
TRUST YES THERE ABSOLUTELY IS.
NOT OF THE AUTHOR. I HAVE NO
CONCERN ABOUT THAT PARTICULAR
AUTHORED WHATSOEVER. BUT THE
INSTITUTION I DO. IN THE YEARS
THAT I WAS GONE AND I CAME BACK
AND PEOPLE SAID JIM MUCH
DIFFERENT. THE LEGISLATURE BEEN
GONE EIGHTEEN YEARS WHAT'S
DIFFERENT. I SAID RESPECT FOR
EACH OTHER. AND RESPECT FOR THE
INSTITUTION AND THE RULES THERE
ARE HAVE GREATLY DIMINISHED. NOW
THE THIRD HOUSE THEY GET THAT.
THEN THEY DO A MAGNIFICENT JOB
OF. ADVOCATING FOR THEIR CLIENTS. EL ALL SIDES ARE DOING SO ON
THIS VERY BILL. BUT TO ME. I'M
WARY OF NEXT YEAR. AND THAT NEXT
STEP THAT WILL NOT MAY BE TAKEN
I REGIONAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
NELSON CENTER PORCHES. HELLO
GOOD PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES OF
THIS ISSUE. FROM MY STANDPOINT
SEEMS THAT. THERE'S TWO SIDES OF
THIS COIN YOU HAVE A MERITORIOUS
NEED. AND THEN YOU HAVE WHAT IS
INEVITABLY A TURF WAR. NOW THE
MERITORIOUS NEED IS THE FACT
THAT WE WANT TO HELP I THINK
EVERYBODY HERE WOULD AGREE WE
WANT TO HELP THE SMALL BATCH
DISTILLERIES. THE TURF WAR IS ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT COIN
COIN. WHERE YOU HAVE- MAJOR
DISTRIBUTORS AND MAJOR
PRODUCERS- WANTING TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT THERE'S NOT THE
PROVERBIAL NOSE UNDER THE TENT.
I HAVE TO AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM TO HIM- THAT.
WE'RE BEING ASKED TO VOTE ON A
BILL THAT IN OF ITSELF DOESN'T
SEEM. ON REASONABLE SHIPPING ITS
SIZE. BUT I THINK ALL OF US
UNDERSTAND. THAT THAT SIZE WILL
INCREASE IN MODIFY OVER TIME.
MEYER I HAVE THE HIGHEST RESPECT
FOR THE SENATOR FROM SANTA
MONICA AND THE SENATOR FROM NAPA
BOTH OF WHOM I THINK ARE MEN OF
THEIR WORD AND ARE DOING A
YEOMAN'S JOB TRYING TO SPEARHEAD
THIS ISSUE. I WOULD HAVE TO
AGREE EARLIER WITH THE COMMENTS
FROM THE SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES THAT THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT IS RIPE FOR BIFURCATION.
THAT WE HAVE A VOTE. ON THE
MERITS OF THE SUPPORTING SMALL
BATCH DISTILLERY OPPORTUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE'VE ALL
LEARNED THE LESSONS OF COVERT.
THERE AE BENEFITS ARE THAT CAN
BE HAD BOTH ON THE CONSUMER SIDE
AND ON THE PRODUCTION SIDE
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN NEED AND
THOSE ARE THE SMALL BATCH FOLKS
. WHERE THIS IS GOING TO GO NEXT
IS GOING TO BE A TURF WAR OF THE
TIER SYSTEM. WILL THERE BE A
DOMINANCE A MONOPOLY IN THE
DISTRIBUTION OUR SYSTEM THAT HAS
BEEN AROUND FOREVER. NOW
ARGUMENTS I MADE IN G. O. WHEN
WE WERE DOING WITH THIS AND I
HAVE STAINED AT THAT POINT AND I
HAVE TO CONFESS- I'M INCLINED TO
ABSTAIN IN THIS SITUATION
BECAUSE WE'RE COMBINING TWO
ISSUES. THAT ON THE- ON THEIR
MERITS SHOULD BE SEPARATED. I
WOULD LOVE IF THEY WOULD JUST
THIS BILL ON ON DISTILLERIES I
THINK IT WOULD BE A FORTY YO.
NOW MOVING INTO THE OTHER MORE
DIFFICULT THING IS HOW DO YOU
HOW DO WE INVOLVE THE TIER
SYSTEM. BECAUSE THERE SHOULD BE
SOME CAPACITY FOR PRODUCERS TO
MAIL DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS. BUT
YOU ALSO HAVE A SYSTEM THAT'S
BEEN IN PLACE FOR DECADES UPON
DECADES UPON DECADES IN ALL THE
LOGISTICS AND INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT TRANSPORTATION
EMPLOYEE BLOCKS. YOU CAN'T JUST
SIMPLY ON DO THAT OVERNIGHT AND
I KNOW THAT THIS BILL SOUNDS
LIKE YOU WOULDN'T BE ON DOING IT
OVERNIGHT BUT IT WILL
IMMEDIATELY BEGIN THAT PROCESS
OF BOTH SIDES GOING TO THEIR
CORNERS IN DUKING IT OUT- THE
VOLUME THAT CAN BE TRANSPORTED.
THROUGH DIRECT CONSUMER SALES
WHAT UNDOUBTEDLY INCREASE SORT
PUSHING OFF THE INEVITABLE. I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND
OF COURSE YOU WANT TO PASS IT
TODAY AND THEN- IT IT'S GOING TO
BE OFF TO THE RACES IN THE
ASSEMBLY. IF THIS WERE TO BE
BIFURCATED I WOULD BE SO PROUD
TO CAST A VOTE IN FAVOR OF
PROMOTING SMALL BATCH
DISTILLERY- CONSUMER SALES. AND
THE NEXT BATTLE WHICH WOULD
ESSENTIALLY BE A POLITICAL WAR
WE ALL KNOW THAT. LET THE MERITS
OF THAT DEBATE UNFOLD. IN LET'S
GO AFTER THE TIER SYSTEM FOR
WHAT IT IS SOMETHING THAT THE
ANTIQUATED BUT YOU CAN'T JUST ON
DO IT WITHOUT A HIGH DEGREE OF
FOR NON PREPARATION PRECAUTION.
IN TIMELINE TO RESPECT THE
INVESTMENT THAT PEOPLE IN THE
INDUSTRY HAVE MADE. ARE NOT JUST
NOW BUT IN THE DECADES PAST.
THANK YOU CENTER BORDERS MEMBERS
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
ALLEN YOU MAY CLOSE I'M SORRY
BUT- IRAN ONE MOMENT CENTRO
TROUBLE YOU GOT ME THERE AT THE
LAST SECOND PLEASE PROCEED. I
APOLOGIZE MADAM CHAIR. SO IT'S
BEEN VERY DIFFICULT- THIS IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE HARDEST
BOATS OR THAT I WILL NOT MAKE
THEM ON THIS FLOOR AS A NEW
MEMBERS ONE OF THE NEWEST
MEMBERS HERE. BEEN TRYING TO
BUILD THOSE RELATIONSHIPS BOTH
HERE- WITH MY COLLEAGUES AS FAR
AS THE TRUST. AND THE GOOD WILL
AND GOOD FAITH IN NEGOTIATING
WITH THE BILLS. AND TAKING THE
COUNCIL FROM EVERYBODY IN TRYING
TO REPRESENT MY DISTRICT- THE
BEST THAT I CAN I AM LISTENING
TO THE CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE- IN
MY DISTRICT ON THAT END. THE ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I DIDN'T
REALLY REASSURED HERE TODAY IS
THE FACT THAT I AM INCREDIBLY.
PLEASED TO HEAR THAT THERE HAS
BEEN CON CONVERSATIONS IN A GO
SHE ASIANS IN THE PROCESS AND
TRYING TO ADDRESSED. OF MANY OF
THE CONCERNS WITHIN THIS BILL
AND THE WILLINGNESS OF THE
AUTHOR TO- TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS AND I ACTUALLY EVEN I'M
VERY PLEASED WITH THAT. I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I FOR
CLARIFICATION PURPOSES THAT THIS
BILL. WILL NOT INCLUDE. IT WILL
BE DIVIDED INTO JUST ADDRESSING
THE ISSUES WITH OUR SMALL
DISTILLERIES AND THAT THEY WILL
BE NARROWED LANGUAGE- AND THAT
AT THE BEER WILL NOT. ABSOLUTELY
WILL NOT BE. INCLUDED IN THIS
NISPEL. IS THAT A QUESTION
CENTER GO TO STAY- JUST. BURKE
THANK YOU. OUR QUESTION I GUESS
THANK OKAY SENATOR ALAN WE TAKE
A QUESTION YES ABSOLUTELY I'M
SEED SO ABS ARE YOU'VE HEARD
BOTH OF US. IN LOCKHART
COMMITMENT THAT BEER IS OUT OF
THE BILL. ON THE ISSUE THAT BOTH
YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUE- ARE FROM
FRESNO REYES WITH REGARDS TO
SMALL DISTILLERIES. ABSENT OVER
OVER AGAIN THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN MY
FOCUS. ARE WE ARE AT A POINT OF
RIGHT NOW RIGHT NOW WITH REGARDS
TO THE BIG FOLKS. ARE WILL ALL
THE BILL ALLOWS FOR IS THERE'S A
THERE'S A THERE'S AN ANNUAL CAP
. BOTH IN TERMS OF THE TOTAL
THAT CAN BE SHIPPED IN A YEAR
AND ALSO THE TOTAL THAT CAN BE
SHIPPED. TO AN INDIVIDUAL. I
HAVE SO NINE LEADERS TO AN
INDIVIDUAL PER YEAR. HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND GALLONS STATEWIDE
FOR THAT THAT DISTILLER'S
LICENSE. I'M NASH ARE A BY THE
WAY WOULD HAVE TO BE THROUGH A
SUBSCRIPTION SERVICE NOW WE HAVE
GONE TO THE OPPOSITION ARE IN
THE- OUR INTEREST IS TO FOCUS ON
PRODUCTS THAT ARE NOT AVAILABLE
IN IN THE RETAIL STORES RIGHT SO
THERE ARE SOME PRODUCTS SOME
SPECIALTY PRODUCTS THAT ARE
PRODUCED BY THE BIG GUYS THAT
ARE SIMPLY NOT SOLD ON ON STORE
SHELVES AND IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE
ECONOMIC SENSE FOR THEM TO BE
SOLD ON SARCELLES BECAUSE THEY
DON'T MOVE AT A VERY FAST CLIP.
THAT'S REALLY OUR FOCUS FOR THEM
I WE HAVE GIVEN IDEA AFTER IDEA
AFTER IDEA TO THE DISTRIBUTORS
AND THEY HAVE SHOT EVERY SINGLE
ONE DOWN WE SAID HEY CAN YOU
COME BACK WITH SOME LANGUAGE
THAT MIGHT WORK THE ANSWER OVER
AND OVER AGAIN HAS BEEN NO IN
THE END OF THE DAY THEY JUST
DON'T WANT TO SEE ANY MECHANISM
FOR THEM TO BE A PART OF THIS
BILL EVEN FOR THOSE PRODUCTS
THAT ARE NOT AVAILABLE IN THE
RETAIL I I'D THAT STORES AROUND
OUR STATE. ARE YOU KNOW SO
THAT'S MY DILEMMA HERE- SENATOR
HE'S IS THE IS THE IS JUST THE
LACK OF COOPERATION- AND IDEAS
FROM THEM WITH REGARDS TO SOME
SORT OF LANGUAGE THAT MIGHT MEET
THE NEEDS THAT WE HAVE EXPRESSED
AND THAT THEY HAVE EXPRESSED
BECAUSE THE END OF THE DAY WE
UNDERSTAND THEIR CENTRAL
ARGUMENT WHICH IS THAT THEY
DON'T WANT PRODUCTS THAT ARE
GOING TO COMPETE WITH THEIR
PRODUCTS THE COMPLETE ANY ANY
PRODUCT THAT IS REGULAR SOLD IN
STORES OF COURSE IS GOING TO
COMPETE WITH OUR PRODUCTS- SO
WE'VE WORKED TO GET THAT
LANGUAGE OUT. A BUT BUT THEY YOU
KNOW THEY THEY'E JUST NOT IN A
PLACE WHERE THEY'VE BEEN WILLING
TO ACCEPT ANYTHING OR EVEN GIVE
US ANY ANY ANY AMENDMENTS THAT
THAT THEY MEET THE GOALS THAT WE
HAVE FOR THOSE SPECIALTY
PRODUCTS THAT'S THE DILEMMA THAT. WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW. AND- YOU
KNOW I'M JUST. THAT WILL BE ABLE
THAT THAT IF WE GET THIS OUT OF
THE SENATE FLOOR WILL WILL BE
ABLE TO WORK IT OUT. I'M YOU
KNOW OVER TO SIMPLY COMMITTEE.
SENATOR BOB THAT'S GOOD. OKAY%
VERY GOOD THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER ALEXANDER WILK. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX TWENTY. THIS
IS A PRO CONSUMER BILL I'D I
AGREE WE WANT TAKE CARE OF OUR
SMALL CRAFT DISTILLERS AND THERE
IS A TURF WAR GOING ON- FOR
THAT'S NOT MY PROBLEM MY PROBLEM
IS. SUPPORTING MY CONSTITUENTS
WANT AND THEY WANT CHOICE IN IN
CHOICE IN THE MARKETPLACE WE ARE
HERE TODAY AT THIS ARBITRARY
DEADLINE BECAUSE OF THE GOOD
FAITH FITH OF THE AUTHOR WHO
HELD IT. AT THE REQUEST OF ALL
PARTIES I'VE SAID ON GEO SO I
WAS THERE FOR THE INFORMATIONAL
HEARING IN NOVEMBER WHICH I
LEARNED A GREAT DEAL ABOUT. AND
THIS IS THIS IS A NEEDED NEEDED
REFORM. I'VE WORKED WITH MANY
I'VE WORKED ON MANY TOUGH ISSUES
WITH THE SENATOR FROM SANTA
MONICA PARTICULARLY AS IT
RELATES TO. LET ALEXION REFORM
AND HE'S KEPT HIS WORD EVERY
TIME. I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE IN
HONOR FOR MANY YEARS TO BE THE
VICE CHAIR OF GEO WITH. WITH THE
DISTINGUISHED SENATOR FROM NAPA
AND HE'S ALWAYS KEPT HIS WORD.
SO THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT
THAT I STILL WOULD LIKE TO SEE-
NARROWED IN THE BILL WHICH I'VE
SHARED WITH BOTH THOSE
GENTLEMEN. I BELIEVE THAT IT
WILL HAPPEN IF YOU WANTTO BRING
PEOPLE TO THE TABLE TO GET A
BILL THAT WORKS FOR ALL PARTIES
WE HAVE TO GET IT OUT OF THIS
HOUSE TODAY. BECAUSE THEN THE
SERIES NEGOTIATION BEGINS AGAIN
AT THIS BILL COMES BACK IN THIS
TOO BROAD I WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
SOME SUPPORT IT BUT I BELIEVE
THESE GENTLEMEN. AND I THINK
THEY'RE GOING TO GET ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE AND ULTIMATELY THIS
IS TO HELP. OUR CONSTITUENTS
BACK HOME HAVE CHOICE IN THE
MARKETPLACE SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR WELCOME
MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE SIR ALAN YOU MAY CLOSE.
JUST REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION. AND WE REALLY
HAVE BEEN TRYING HARD TO GET TO
A PLACE WHERE WE CAN GET THIS.
BILL SO WE WOULDN'T OF HAD TO
HAVE THIS KIND OF FIGHT HERE IS
THE SORT OF DISCUSSION THIS
UNCERTAINTY. ON THIS. ON THIS
FLOOR. ARE YOUR FRIENDS IN LABOR
ARE TAKING CUES FROM THEIR
EMPLOYERS TO DISTRIBUTORS. OUR
DISTRIBUTORS JUST DON'T WANT TO
SEE ANY CHANGES. TO THE CURRENT
LAW UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCE AND
THEY JUST MADE IT REALLY CLEAR
TO US- AND THAT'S BEEN OUR
CHALLENGE THAT'S BEEN OUR
TALENTS- SO WITH THAT I ASK THAT
YOU GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
TO GO OVER THE SIMPLY. SEE IF WE
CAN GET THESE ISSUES ADDRESSED
IF WE CAN'T THAT'S NOT COMING
BACK. ARE YOU KNOW IN THE END OF
THE DAY I WITH THE BIGGEST
PORTIONS OF THE BILL I THINK OF
THE ISSUES THAT PEOPLE SEEM TO
AGREE WITH. OUR OUR OUR OUR OUR
VERY MERITORIOUS THERE'S A FEW
SMALL ISSUES THAT. ARE JUST.
PRICKLY AND WE'RE JUST HOPING WE
CAN GET THEM ADDRESSED WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO GET IT BACK. OVER
HERE BUT- I APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S. THE DISCUSSION I.
EVAN CONFIDENCE AYE I RESPECT
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
ALAN MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA
ATKINS I BAKER. FOR JUST.
CABALLERO QUARTET THREE. DALLY I
DODD I TORONTO. EGGMAN I GLAZER
HI GONZALEZ. GROWTH HERTZBERG.
WESTERN I HER TADO. JONES I
KAMLAGER. LAYERED I LEYVA. LIMON
FIVE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ. MEN
NEWMAN. NIELSEN. NO I TROUBLED.
PAN PORTANTINO I ROTH. RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN. NUMBER I WOULD
CASTING AYE WIENER NO WELL I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA WE'RE BACK- REMOVAL
OKAY. PORGES CABALLERO. CORTELLI
THEY'RE AWESOME. GONZALEZ GROWTH
HERTZBERG HER TADO. KAMLAGER
LEYVA. MELENDEZ MAN. NEWMAN A
CHOI BOGUE I. PAN ROTH STERN
SENATE REMOVES THE CALL MEMBERS
WE ARE NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE SENATOR CORTESE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTEEN BY
SENATOR CORTEZ HE AN ACT
RELATING TO WORKERS COMPENSATION
. SENATOR CORTESE. THE PRESIDENT
OF A RISE TODAY 2% SB TWO
THIRTEEN WHICH WILLCREATE A
STREAMLINED ELIGIBILITY FOR
WORKER'S COMPENSATION FOR THOSE
EMPLOYEES PROVIDE DIRECT PATIENT
CARE IN ACUTE HOSPITAL SETTINGS
AND FACE A HIGH RISK OF ILLNESS
AND INJURY ON THE JOB INCLUDING
CONDITIONS SUCH AS INFECTIOUS
DISEASE MUSCULOSKELETAL INJURY
IN COVERT NINETEEN. WORKERS
COMPENSATION PRESUMPTIONS
CURRENTLY EXISTING CALIFORNIA
FOR FIRST RESPONDERS IN MALE
DOMINATED PROFESSIONS INCLUDING
LAW ENFORCEMENT FIRE. ALL NURSES
AND HEALTH CARE WORKERS
OVERWHELMINGLY WOMEN ACT THE
SAME PROTECTIONS. SB TWO
THIRTEEN SIMPLY EXTENDS SIMILAR
WORKERS COMPENSATION
PRESUMPTIONS TO NURSES AND OTHER
HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND IN DOING
SO THIS BILL SEEKS TO MODERNIZE
OUTDATED LAWS. AND ACHIEVE
GREATER GENDER EQUITY IN OUR
STATE. FOR THIS REASON WE SECURE
THE SUPPORT THE CALL OF THE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WOMEN'S CAUCUS
NANCY FOWLER. AND THE CHAIR
PLANS TO BRING THIS FORWARD TO
THE FULL PARTY FORWARD FOR AN
INDOOR SMOKE BUT JUST A FEW
WEEKS. WE'VE ALSO SECURED THE
SUPPORT OF THE COUNTY SANTA
CLARA HOME TO THE SECOND LARGEST
PUBLIC HEALTH. SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA. AND COMPILED EVEN
MORE EXTENSIVE RESEARCH TO
JUSTIFY EACH SPECIFIC
PRESUMPTION INCLUDED IN THIS
BILL. I WILL NOTE THAT THIS
RESEARCH BEEN SHARED WITH EACH
OF YOUR OFFICES. LET ME PAUSE
AND SAY THAT I HAVE AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW. SIR PREVIOUSLY FOR
TWELVE YEARS ON THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
WHICH AS I SAID RUNS ONE OF THE
LARGEST PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
SYSTEMS IN THE UNITED STATES.
MULTIPLE HOSPITALS MULTIPLE
CLINICS THOUSANDS OF HOSPITAL
WORKERS. IT'S ALSO A COUNTY THAT
HAS A VERY ROBUST PRIVATE HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. SO I'M ACUTELY
AWARE OF EQUITY ISSUES THAT
PERVADE OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
FAIRNESS ISSUES. FOR A VERY LONG
TIME. I HAVE A BEEN ON TOP OF
THOSE ISSUES AND I'VE ACTED TO
DRESS THEM IN MY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CAPACITY AND NOW HERE
IN THE STATE SENATE. AND I'M
COMMITTED TO BRINGING THESE
EQUITY ISSUES FORWARD. HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE TO LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD. CAN FINALLY CLOSE
GENDER GAPS THAT PERVADE OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM. I WANT TO GET
JUST A BIT DEEPER INTO WHAT TYPE
OF EQUITY ISSUES EXIST AND WHY.
EXISTING LAW ONLY PROVIDES
CERTAIN TYPES OF FRONT LINE
PROFESSIONALS. ELIGIBILITY FOR
WORKER'S COMPENSATION
PRESUMPTIONS. THIS INCLUDES EMTS
PARAMEDICS FIREFIGHTERS AND
POLICE OFFICERS ALL OF WHICH ARE
CURRENTLY MALE DOMINATED FIELDS
. ACCORDING TO THE CENSUS
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR SEVEN OUT OF
EIGHT POLICE OFFICERS OR MEN
NINETEEN OUT OF TWENTY
FIREFIGHTERS ARE MEN AND THREE
OUT OF FOUR EMTS. ARE MEN.
MEANWHILE FRONTLINE WORKERS WHO
WORK IN THE HEALTHCARE SETTING
SUCH AS NURSES. THOSE ON THE
FRONT LINES OF THE PANDEMIC OVER
THE LAST. COUPLE OF YEARS ARE
NOT ENTITLED TO THE SAME WORKERS
COMPENSATION PRESUMPTIONS.
NURSES HAVE ZERO. WORKERS
COMPENSATION PRESUMPTIONS. THIS
IS DESPITE THE FACT THAT NURSES
PROTECT THE SAME POPULATION IN
OUR HOSPITALS. THE PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS PROTECT IN THE FIELD.
NINE OUT OF TEN REGISTERED
NURSES ARE WOMEN. ACCORDING TO
THE BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS
IN TWENTY TWENTY WORKPLACE
HAZARDS THAT REQUIRED AT LEAST
ONE DAY OFF OF WORK. TOTAL TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FOR FIREFIGHTERS.
TWO HUNDRED FOR POLICE OFFICERS
THE TOOL FOR REGISTERED NURSE
NURSES WITH SEVENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND FORTY
. THE CORE OF THIS BILL IS
SIMPLE. SB TWO THIRTEEN
RECOGNIZES AND ADDRESSES THE
GLARING INEQUITY IN CALIFORNIA
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM.
THAT CORRECTS A HISTORICAL WRONG
MADE DURING A VERY DIFFERENT
TIME LONG AGO. EQUITY IS ONLY
POSSIBLE WHEN ALL FRONT LINE
PROFESSIONALS WHO FACE THE SAME
RISK OF ILLNESS AND INJURY DUE
TO THE NATURE OF THEIR WORK ARE
GIVEN THE SAME GUARANTEE
BENEFITS. HOW MANY MORE YEARS
MUST PASS AND HOW MANY MORE
EXCUSES ME WE MAKE BEFORE WE DO
WHAT'S RIGHT. OPPONENTS MAY
ARGUE THAT THE BILL ROUSSEL. IN
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
FRAUDULENT CLAIM AND BANKRUPT
HOSPITALS THIS IS SIMPLY NOT
TRUE. CONSIDERING THE FACT THAT
ALL PRESUMPTIONS IN THE BILL CAN
BE REBUTTED. EMPLOYERS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DISPUTE ANY CLAIMS.
SB TWO THIRTEEN EXPLICITLY
PROTECTS IMPORTERS RIGHT TO DO
SO. THIS BILLS RETURNING AFTER
FOUR VOTE IN JUNE YOU MAY
RECALL. INSENSIBLE DESPITE MY
RELUCTANCE AGREED TO SCALE BACK
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL TO ADDRESS
. CONCERNS BROUGHT FORWARD BY MY
COLLEAGUES. THIS BILL HAS BEEN
AMENDED TO LIMIT THE CANCER
PRESUMPTIONS TO SPECIFIC TYPES
OF CANCERS. WITH NEXUS TO ACUTE
CARE HOSPITALS TO ADD CO AUTHORS
INTO REMOVED THE SUNSET ON THE
CURRENT CODE NINETEEN
PRESUMPTION. BUT WHICH WAS
LEGISLATIVE PREVIOUSLY BY THIS
LEGISLATURE TO SET TO EXPIRE. UP
ALREADY THIS YEAR JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWO LET ME SAY RELUCTANT
AS I MAY BE I APPRECIATE THE
COOPERATION PARTICULARLY THOSE
WHO HAVE COME FORWARD WITH
SPECIFIC AMENDMENTS THAT DON'T
WATER DOWN THE INTENT OF THE
BILL. WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT
AGAIN IS LEVELING THE PLAYING
FIELD. SB TWO THIRTEEN IS A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION TOWARDS
RESOLVING THE ECONOMIC AND
GENDER INEQUITY THAT REMAINS IN
OUR SOCIETY TO THIS DAY. ALL
THREE THIS BILL. HAS BEEN A
FURTHER I OPENING EXPERIENCE.
AFTER ALL THOSE YEARS AS A
COUNTY SUPERVISOR. I HAD A
RECORD OF THE DRESS UP
ADDRESSING FIRSTHAND IN
CORRESPONDENCE IN BOATS AND
VOTERS IN FACE TO FACE MEETINGS
HOSPITALS UNDER CUTTING THE
WORKFORCE. PUTTING PROFITS OVER
PEOPLE IN THEIR WORKERS. SO
AGAIN I MADE A PROMISE TO MYSELF
TO DO THIS KIND OF WORK UPON
ARRIVING HERE. IN THIS WILL BE
THE LAST TIME. THAT YOU HEAR ME
COMING FROM A PLACE OF EQUITY
AND FAIRNESS JUST LIKE SO MANY
OF YOU HAVE AND WILL CONTINUE TO
DO SO. THE GAP IN ACCESS TO
WORKERS COMPENSATION EXPERIENCE
PER NURSES IS WRONG THAT MUST BE
CORRECTED. LET ME JUST SAY. JUST
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THAT. IN
USED A REAL LIFE EXAMPLE ONE
THAT ARE BROUGHT UP LAST JUNE.
AGAIN AS I JUST STATED BASED ON
LABOR STATISTICS. KEEP IN MIND
FIREFIGHTERS 90% MEN NURSES 90%
WOMEN. WHEN A FIREFIGHTER EMT
ARRIVES AT THE EMERGENCY ROOM IN
A HANDS OFF A PATIENT ON A
GURNEY. IN ACQUIRES A HERNIA
FROM LIFTING THE PATIENT HE- HE
HAS A WORKERS COMP PRESUMPTION
RIGHT NOW IN THAT MOMENT. WHEN
HE HAS A PATIENT ON THE GURNEY
OVER TO THE WOMAN NURSE. WOMAN
NURSE AND SHE HURT HER BACK SHE
HAS NO WORKERS COMPENSATION
PRESUMPTION ST CONTINUE OF CARE.
LITERALLY THE SAME ACUITY OF
CARE SAME FRONTLINE STATUS IN
THAT SPLIT SECOND. DURING THE
HEAD OFF THE CAR PRESUMPTION
DISAPPEARS. WHAT'S HAPPENING
THERE. I ASK AGAIN WHAT'S
HAPPENING THERE IF NOT GENDER
THIS IS NOT ABOUT HOSPITALS
VERSUS NURSES OR UNIONS VERSUS
NOT PERSONS. VERSUS NON UNIONS
IT'S ABOUT EQUITY. COLLEAGUES I
DO NOT COME HERE TO STAND FOR
THE STATUS QUO WHEN IT COMES TO
EQUITY AND I DON'T THINK. MOST
OF YOU IF ANY OF YOU ARE HERE
FOR THAT EITHER. I THINK WE'RE
HERE. TO ESTABLISH EQUITY
ESPECIALLY IN AN AREA LIKE THIS
. THE PRESIDENT IN THIS CASE. IS
WHAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT FOR OVER
FIFTY YEARS IN THIS STATE AND IN
THIS COUNTRY. THAT WORK WOMEN DO
IS EQUAL TO WORK THAT MEN DO AND
THEY SHOULD BE COMPENSATED THAT
WAY. WORKERS COMPENSATION SHOULD
PULL THAT RULE. I ASK YOU TO
STAND WITH ME TODAY FOR EQUITY
FOR ALL FRONTLINE WORKERS. IN
EQUITY FOR WOMEN AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER CORTESE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY EXCUSE ME I'M
SORRY CENTER BECKER. THANK YOU.
I'M WHEN A FEW COMMENTS SEVENTY
SEVEN GRATEFUL TO OUR WORKFORCE
OF NURSES ESPECIALLY FOR THEIR
HARD WORK DURING THEIR THIS
PANDEMIC AND I DO SUPPORT A
PREVIOUS VERSION OF THIS BILL-
AS WITH AND I DO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT A FEW OF THE PRESUMPTIONS
FROM IMPLEMENTATION STANDPOINT
FROM SOME NURSES ARE SPOKEN TO
INCLUSION OF CANCER ASTHMA COPD
ARE. CHALLENGING AND I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE NEW DATA BEFORE WE
AND TRY THESE PERMANENTLY. IN
LAW I DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
COMMITMENT TO TAKE OUT COPD CAN
REVISIT IN THE THESE IN THE
ASSEMBLY IF THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD TODAY. I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR ALL HIS HARD
WORK. ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR BAKER CENTER ALAN.
MEMBERS. AMONG THE- MEMBERS I
YOU KNOW I DO WANNA I WANNA ECHO
THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FROM THE CEMETERY
AREA I YOU THIS IS A BILL THAT I
KNOW HAS A LOT OF MERIT I ALSO
KNOW THAT I HAS NOT BEEN
SUBSTANTIVELY CHANGED SINCE IT
FAILED TO GET OFF THE FLOOR I AT
THE END OF THE YEAR LAST YEAR.
ON I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
CHANGES THAT ARE MADE
SUBSTANTIVELY ADDRESSED THE
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED BY MANY
OF US WHO VOTED FOR IT- AND
THOSE WHO. ARE WHO OPPOSED. AND
WHO WANT TO SEE. OVER MORE OF A
NEXUS BETWEEN. THE THE TYPES OF
INJURIES- ARE IN THE WORKPLACE
THAT THE FOLKS TO BE GIVING THIS
GIVEN THIS REBUTTAL PRESUMPTION
WOULD- WOULD WOULD WOULD WOULD
OBTAIN NOW I'VE HAD SUBSTANTIAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR I
APPRECIATE. THE HARD WORK THAT
HE'S PUT IN TRYING TO TALK ME
THROUGH A LOT OF THESE ISSUES. I
KNOW THAT HE'S HIMSELF IS IN A
DIFFICULT SPOT. I AND- YOU KNOW
I'M CERTAINLY OPEN TO GIVING HIM
THE OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP WORKING
ON THIS IN A I HAVE
UNFORTUNAELY OR FORTUNATELY
YEAH I DON'T DISAGREE WITH OUR-
OUR DEAN WHEN HE WHEN HE TALKS
ABOUT THE BOTH THE UPSIDES AND
DOWNSIDES OF. THE WAY WE DO OUR
WORK AND THE FACT IT OFTENTIMES
DEALS CAN'T GET STRUCK OVER
HERE- FOR VARIOUS REASONS AND
THEN YOU HAVE TO GO TO THE
ASSEMBLY WORK THINGS OUT AND I
HAVE A LOT OF CONFIDENCE IN THE
AUTHOR AND IS GOOD FAITH- BUT I
WILL POINT OUT- THAT. AND I'VE
BEEN. NONPLUSSED BY THE- THE
CHALLENGES OF GETTING ANY
SUBJECT CHANGES MADE TO THIS
BILL- BUT UP TO THIS POINT. I
BUT I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT
THE- THAT THE OFFICE GOT A LONG
ROAD AHEAD ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE.
AND IT'S WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING
I'M I'M WILLING TO GIVE HIM THE
COURTESY OF BEING ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE-
THAT I KNOW HE CARES A GREAT
DEAL ABOUT. THANK YOU CENTER
ALLEN CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- I FIRST WANT TO
START BY ACKNOWLEDGING HOW
IMPORTANT OUR FRONT LINE WORKERS
ARE RIGHT NURSES SWEET VALUE AND
WE CARE VERY MUCH FOR THEM AND
DIED TO APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
THEY DO- ON BUT THIS BILL IN
PARTICULAR- YOU KNOW AS THE
AUTHOR STATED IT'S A LITTLE BIT
MORE NARAL BUT- FROM THE LAST
TIME WE CAME TO THE FLOOR THERE
WERE SOME- COMMITMENTS AND- THE
COMMITMENTS WERE NOT. ARE NOT
NOT FOLLOW THROUGH AT THIS
POINT- I KNOW THAT THERE'S A
TIME LIMITATION HOWEVER AWESOME
OF THINGS THAT WERE SUPPOSED TO
BE TAKEN OUT ARE NOT AT THIS
POINT AND I ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT I THINK ALL OF US
WOMEN HERE VERY MUCH. INTERESTED
IN TAKING CARE OF WOMEN AND
BEING SUPPORTIVE OF WOMEN'S
ISSUES MAKING SURE THERE'S
ADEQUATE HE'S FOR WOMEN BUT YOU
KNOW I PARTICULARLY COMING FROM
L. A. COUNTY RECEIVED A LETTER
OF OPPOSITION FROM OUR L. A.
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AS
WE ALL KNOW ALL THEY'RE ALL
WOMEN INCLUDING SOME THAT HAVE
SERVED ON THIS FLOOR THAT OUR
LABOR CHAMPIONS WHO ARE OPPOSING
THE BILL. SEOUL CLEARLY THERE'S
SOME DEFICIENCIES THERE AS WELL
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED ON I
WANT TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT TO
GET SUPPORT NURSES OP BUT IT'S A
LITTLE TOO BROAD AND THERE'S A
LOT OF ISSUES THAT I HAVE RIGHT
NOW THEY HAVE NOT BEEN ADDRESSED
SO WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY I WILL
ALSO LAY OFF THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER RUBIO MEMBERS FURTHER
QUESTIONS. OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING SIR CORTESE MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MENTAL- IT EIGHT DO
WANT TO THE CLARIFY TO MORE
THINGSMIKE. SOME ONE OF THEM IS
WE DO HAVE A LETTER THIS BEEN
DISTRIBUTED EVERYONE FROM.
SUPERVISOR SHEILA KEWL FROM THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS COUNTY LOS
ANGELES- IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
. SO WHATEVER. HAS HAPPENED
THERE LOS ANGELES SO. IF THERE
WAS OPPOSITION IS CERTAINLY NOT
UNANIMOUS FROM THAT BOARD. THAT
SAID- I DID MAKE A COMMITMENT- A
TO ONE OF MY COLLEAGUE SIR. ONE
OF THOSE WHO JUST SPOKE AND I
APPRECIATE THE COURTESIES. IN I
ENTERED IN MY- IN MY
PRESENTATION OF MY OPENING IF
YOU WILL. NOT INDICATING THAT
BESIDES THE MEMBERS HAD ALREADY
CROSSED WHICH I ALREADY SPOKE
TO- WE WILL BE. A TWO LEADING.
COPD AS A PRESUMPTION FROM THE
BILL- I PROMISED LAST JUNE. THAT
LACKING NEXUS FOR ANY OF THESE
IT WOULD BE DELETED- WE FEEL
THAT THE NEXUS IS BEEN VERY VERY
WE CURRENTLY ESTABLISHED ON
ASTHMA I HAVE NOT ESTABLISHED
THAT IN THE LAST SIX MONTHS IN
COPD- AND I FEEL LIKE THE
AMENDMENTS ON CANCER OR ABOUT AS
GOOD AS THEY'RE GOING TO BE BUT
WILL CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OTHER HOUSE FOR FORTUNATE ENOUGH
TO HAVE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY. I
GET THIS ALL THE HOUSE OF ORIGIN
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF MATTER
PRESENT THANK YOU CENTER CORTESE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA I ATKINS
AYE BAKER. PORGES NO CUT BY ADAM
HI PROTESTING HI DALLY NO DODD.
YOU'RE AWESOME I EGGMAN I GLAZER
NO GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH.
HERTZBERG FIVE WESTERN. HI
FURTADO. HUESO I TO KNOW.
HURTADO JONES NO KAMLAGER. I
LAYERED. I LEYVA AYE LIMÓN AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NO MAN.
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN NO- CHAU BOTH
NO HAN. PORTANTINO RALPH. RUBIO
SKINNER. I STERN HI NUMBER.
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER AYE
WILK NOW PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN I BAKER. DODD
GROWTH HER TADO I. MEN PAN
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO. NUMBER
SENATE REMOVES THE CALL MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN SENATOR GONZALEZ MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE FORTY TWO BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ AN ACT RELATING TO AIR
POLLUTION SENATOR GONZALEZ THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL THREE FORTY TWO WHICH WILL
IN MY OPINION UPLIFT THE VOICES
OF THOSE MOVIES DECADES OF
HISTORIC AND SYSTEMIC
ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION. BY
ADDING A REPRESENTATION TO THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT GOVERNING
BOARD AS MANY- MEMBERS MAY OR
MAY NOT KNOW THE CURRENT BOARD
THAT IS COMPOSED OF FIFTEEN
MEMBERS OVER TWO THIRDS WHICH
ARE TEN ELECTED MEMBERS. AND
THREE THAT OUR STATE APPOINTED
MEMBERS ONE BY THE GOVERNOR WHEN
BY THE SPEAKER IN OUR PRO TEM.
DESPITE SIGNIFICANT QUALITY
IMPROVEMENTS OVER THE LAST
DECADE THE SOUTH COAST AIR BASIN
HAS SOME HAS HAD SOME OF THE
WORST AIR QUALITY IN THE NATION
IT'S NOT A HARD TO FIND REPORTS
LIKE IN THE L. A. TIMES AND CAL
MATTERS AND SUCH THAT HAVE SAID
ON A DAILY BASIS. THERE ARE
RESIDENTS THAT ARE DEALING WITH
SOME OF THE WORST IN THE WHOLE
NATION IN FACT OVER TWENTY TIMES
TONS MORE- ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF
OUR PORTS CONGESTION.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES HAVE
HISTORICALLY OPEN OVER BURDENED
WITH THE IMPACTS OF AIR
POLLUTION AND CONTAMINATION AND
SADLY THESE COMMUNITIES ARE IN
MY DISTRICT OF SOUTHEAST LOS
ANGELES ALONG THE I SEVENTY
CORRIDOR WEST LONG BEACH AS WELL
AS PLACES LIKE WILMINGTON AND IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE. THEY'VE BEEN
PLAGUED BY POLLUTION FROM
REFINERIES METAL AND MEAT
PROCESSING PLANTS AND BAD ACTOR
BUSINESSES AND THEIR. FIRST
FORCED TO PAY THE HIGHEST COST.
APPOINTING TO THE A DEEP THAT.
AND WORK DIRECTLY WITH COMMUNITY
THAT ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
BURDENED BY HIGH LEVELS OF
POLLUTION WILL BRING VALUABLE
EXPERTISE. AND WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING MY OFFICE HAS BEEN
WORKING IN GOOD FAITH WITH
SOMEBODY STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
LABOR COMMUNITY AS WELL AS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVOCATES
- WE HAVE BEEN WORKING FOR OVER
A YEAR TO INSURE THAT WE GET
THIS RIGHT. NOW ALTHOUGH THIS IS
NOT PERFECT AND WE STILL HAVE A
LOT MORE WORK TO DO. WE ARE
WORKING AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO
SO IN GOOD FAITH SHOULD THIS
BILL MOVED OFF THE FLOOR TODAY.
IN FACT- WHEN I BROUGHT THIS
BILL UP IN MARCH WE WORKED ON IT
DIDN'T HAVE ANY OPPOSITION UNTIL
SIX MONTHS LATER AND AT THE SIX
MONTH MARK WE DID RECEIVE A LOT
OF OPPOSITION FROM OUR- OUR
FRIENDS IN LABOR. AND WHAT WE
HAD WORKED ON WAS A FEW
DIFFERENT SCENARIOS WHETHER IT
WAS A LABOR REPRESENTATIVE. OR
SUCH THAT WE CAN TALK ABOUT WE
ARE STILL. DEBATING THOSE ITEMS
NOW. BUT I WANT TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT AFTER THIS YEAR. WE CANNOT
DELAY THIS PROGRESS ANY LONGER.
WE HAVE TO ACT NOW. AND IN FACT
SB THREE FORTY TWO WAS ACTUALLY
TESTED POLICY IDEA. IT HAS BEEN
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE BEFORE.
MANY TIMES. IN FACT IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN JUST THREE
YEARS AGO THE SAN DIEGO AIR
POLLUTION BOARD VIA. AB FOUR
TWENTY THREE. ALSO ADDED. AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVOCATE.
THE PERSON THAT. HAS A PUBLIC
HEALTH BACKGROUND AND SOMEONE
WITH A SCIENTIFIC BACKGROUND. TO
KNOW WITH NO OPPOSITION IN FACT
I BELIEVE IT HAD. MINOR LABOR-
SUPPORT. AND SO I KNOW THAT THIS
IS. AN IMPORTANT VERY IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION TODAY I LOOK FORWARD
TO THE DEBATE. BUT I ALSO LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THAT WORK-
AGAIN I AM THE CHILD OF A-
TEAMSTER THE CHILD OF. SOMEBODY
THAT UNDERSTANDS- WHAT IT WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO LIVE EVERY SINGLE
DAY WITH- SOMEBODY THAT. IS IN
THE LABOR COMMUNITY. BUT WE HAVE
A LOT OF WORK TO DO SO MEMBERS
WE CANNOT DELAY THIS ANY LONGER
I'M LOOKING TO LEVEL UP THE
DISCUSSIONS I LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSING THIS WITH- OUR LABOR
PARTNERS AS WELL AS OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVOCATES.
AND AGAIN. LOOKING FORWARD TO.
THE DISCUSSION BUT- WHAT'S ON
THE TABLE HERE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER SOMEONE WITH A
SCIENTIFIC BACKGROUND- WE CAN
CERTAINLY GET THROUGH THIS FOR
OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN ALL
FOUR COUNTIES. SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR GONZALEZ
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR CALM WATER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I AM A- JOINT CO
AUTHOR ON THIS BILL- IN SO. I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS- I YOU
KNOW FOR FOLKS WHO MIGHT NOT
KNOW WE'VE BEEN HAVING A SERIES
OF. CLIMATE DISCUSSIONS WITH- A
SMALL GROUP OF REALLY COMMITTED
SENATORS AND WE'VE BEEN TALKING
WITH FOLKS ALL ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM AS IT RELATES TO
ENVIRONMENTALISM. AND HOW THE
STATE TACKLES IT. AND I THINK
THE BEAUTY OF THESE DISCUSSIONS
IS THAT WE FIND WAYS. TO CREATE
A SPACE AT THE TABLE FOR
EVERYONE RECOGNIZING THAT NOT
EVERYONE AGREES. ON EVERY
JOURNEY THAT WE SHOULD BE TAKING
BUT EVERYONE CERTAINLY AGREES
THAT WE HAVE TO GET TO THE
DESTINATION IN THE DESTINATION
IS. YOU KNOW HOW DO WE- ATTACKED
OUR CLIMATE HOW DO WE PROTECT
JOBS HOW DO WE INFUSE INVESTMENT
IN A WAY THAT IS EQUITABLE
ACROSS ALL PARTS OF THIS STATE.
AND SO I'M REALLY TAKING THAT
CHARGE TO HEART YOU KNOW AS I'M
LOOKING AT ALL OF THESE BILLS. I
KNOW THAT THERE IS A LONG ROAD
AHEAD FOR SB THREE FOUR TWO. AND
I HAVE A LOT OF FAITH IN THE
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL THAT SHE
WILL CONTINUE TO DO THE WORK TO
TALK WITH OPPOSITION. TO FIND A
PATH FORWARD I AM ALSO OF THE
MINDSET THAT. IF FOLKS DON'T
HAVE A PLACE AT THE TABLE. THEY
WILL FIND A WAY TO GET TO THE
TABLE. IN WAYS THAT MIGHT NOT BE
COMFORTABLE. AND SO HOW DO WE
WORK AS DILIGENTLY AND
AUTHENTICALLY AS POSSIBLE TO
CREATE THAT SPACE BECAUSE
EVERYONE IS WORKINGREALLY HARD
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES AROUND. NO
CLIMATE PROTECTION. GREEN ENERGY
CLEAN ENERGY AND CLEAN ECONOMY
AND EQUITABLE INVESTMENTS IN ALL
OF THIS SPACE- SO I RESPECT WHAT
THE- SENATOR FROM LONG BEACH HAS
BEEN DOING ON THIS AND I KNOW
THAT SHE WILL GET TO THE FINISH
LINE AND I'M JUST IMPLORING THAT
WE ALL LEAN IN AND SUPPORT THE
AUTHOR- IN THIS WORK BECAUSE IT
IS IMPORTANT. I'M AND HAVING THE
SEATS AT THE TABLE WHERE
EVERYONE FEELS LIKE THEY HAVE A
VOICE- IS IMPORTANT AN OPENING
THOSE SPACES FOR FOLKS WHO HAVE
FELT LIKE THEY HAVE BEEN
DISENFRANCHISED OR KEPT FROM IT
IS I THINK WHAT MOST OF US ARE
TRYING TO DO IN THIS WORK AROUND
EQUITY SO I AM URGING AND I VOTE
ON THREE FOUR TWO AND I'M JUST
URGING CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE OPPOSITION. TO FIGURE
OUT A PATHWAY FORWARD- BECAUSE
IT WILL TAKE ALL OF US IT WILL
TAKE ALL OF US. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET IT RIGHT. AS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THESE IMPORTANT
ISSUES THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER CALM WATER SENATOR. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- JUST TAKING
OFF OF WHAT. THE SENATOR JUST
MENTIONED IT DOES TAKE ALL OF US
AND I KNOW THAT ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS WHO HAVE WILL HAVE
A DISAGREEMENT ON THIS. ON THIS
BILL BUT I KNOW STAKEHOLDERS
WANT TO END UP IN THE SAME PLACE
WANT TO END UP WHERE WE HAVE
GOOD JOBS BECAUSE NOTHING IS
WORSE FOR A COMMUNITY. THAT THE
HAVE CRAPPY JOBS WHERE YOU HAVE
THE WORKING POOR- I KNOW THAT'S
WHAT. OUR LABOR STANDS FOR I
ALSO KNOW THAT THOSE SAME
COMMUNITIES THAT GET CRAPPY JOBS
AND THEY ARE THE WORKING POOR
ARE THE SAME ONES WHO GET. OF
YOU KNOW THE AIR CONTAMINATION
THE WATER THE SOIL. OUT WE JUST
CAN'T KEEP GOING OUT THIS WITH
EACH OTHER- SOUL I AM VERY
HOPEFUL THAT. OF THE SENATOR
FROM LONG BEACH WHAT WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK REALLY HARD TO
GET AT A PLACE WHERE WE CAN ALL
SUPPORT EACH OTHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUSSELL.
MEMBERS OTHER DISCUSSIONS CENTER
PAM. OKAY THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I JUST WANT TO FIRST
OF ALL I RECOGNIZE- FACT THAT
THIS IS A BILL THAT AFFECTS THE
IT SENATORS DISTRICT- AND ALSO-
UNDERSTAND THAT- APPRECIATE HER
COMMITMENT TO- SEEK AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL THAT WOULD THEN
FOCUS ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH
ASPECTS TO HAVE- ONE MEMBERS BE
A PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER. AND THE
OTHER TO BE AND SCIENTISTS WITH
EXPERTISE IN AIR QUALITY-
SIMILAR TO WHAT SHE POINTED OUT
SAN DIEGO A LEGISLATION THAT
THAT PASSED THE LEGISLATURE
WITHOUT TO ACTUALLY ON THE
SIGNATURE OPPOSITION AND THE
TRYING TO DO SIMILAR THINGS TO
ADDRESS THESE AIR QUALITY ISSUES
IN HER DISTRICT AND TO ME THOSE
ARE SEEM TO BE REASONABLE-
GOALS- TO PURSUE IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND- EXPECT AND CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE HER COMMITMENT AND
LOOK FORWARD TO. FOR MAKING THIS
CHANGES IN THE ASSEMBLY THANK
YOU THANK YOU CENTER PAM CENTER
WINNER. I THANK YOU MATTER
PRESIDENT I RISING SUPPORT. OF
SB THREE FORTY TWO I HAVE TO SAY
WE IT IS- IT MAKES ME SAD THAT
WE HAVE IS CONTINUING. COMPLEX
BETWEEN. THESE TWO CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT HOLES OF SUPPORTING
WORKING PEOPLE AND GREAT JOBS
SUPPORTING LABOR WHICH SO MANY
OF US DO- AND RECOGNIZING. NOT
JUST THE EXISTENTIAL FOR THE
CLIMATE CHANGE POSES THE CLIMATE
CHANGE IS OFTEN IT'S VERY
NEBULOUS FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE
THIS SORT OF. THING- OVER ARCHES
EVERYTHING- SUCH JUST ABOUT
CLIMATE ACTION IT'S ABOUT MAKING
SURE. THAT PEOPLE AND CHILDREN
HAVE CLEAN AIR THEY CAN BREED IN
ERROR THAT DOES NOT MAKE THEM IS
SET. DIRECTLY NOT INDIRECT
NEBULOUS. IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE BUT LITERALLY BREATHING
AIR AND. THAT AIR MAKES YOU SICK
. AND WE KNOW. WE KNOW
TRAGICALLY NOT SURPRISING- BUT
ALWAYS BEARS REPEATING THAT WHEN
IT COMES TO THIRTY. UNHEALTHY
DANGEROUS AIR NOT ALL
COMMUNITIES ARE AFFECTED THE
SAME WAY. AND WE KNOW THAT
BECAUSE OF ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM
. IT IS PREDOMINANTLY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. WERE SEEN
AS INCREASED RATES OF ASTHMA
CANCER AND OTHER DISEASES
BECAUSE OF THE DIRTY
CONTAMINATED DANGEROUS ERA AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT WE
CHARGE AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT'S WITH TRYING TO
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY AND I THINK-
BRINGING THIS. ADDITIONAL VOICE
I TO THE TABLE AND A VERY FORMAL
WAY MAKES ALL THE SENSE IN THE
WORLD ON SUPPORTING THIS- I KNOW
THAT THE AUTHOR WILL CONTINUE
HAVING DIALOGUE- AND I KNOW THAT
WE CAN WE WILL EVENTUALLY GET
THERE I MEAN KNOWLEDGE MEN AND
THE UNION. OF THESE TWO
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT GOALS OF
SUPPORTING WORKING PEOPLE
CREATING HIGH PAYING JOBS AND
PRESERVING HIGH PAYING JOBS. AND
NOT POISONING OUR CHILDREN.
THANK YOU CENTER WIENER SENATOR
LAMONT. THANK YOU MEMBERS I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I
ALSO RISE A SOMEONE WHO WAS
THERE WHO SUPPORTED WHEN WE DID
THIS FOR SAN DIEGO FOR CARBON
FOR THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY- IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT THIS PARTICULAR
BILL. SEEMS TO HAVE ISSUES BUT I
URGE THAT YOU KNOW OUR HOUSE AND
OUR COLLEAGUES TO REALLY THINK
ABOUT THE VALUE OF BRINGING IN-
NOT JUST COMMUNITIES OF COLOR-
TO THE TABLE TO BE HEARD AND TO
INFLUENCE PUBLIC POLICY BUT ALSO
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH LEADERS AND
SCIENTIST ON SO MANY ISSUES WE
HAVE ADVOCATED TO HAVE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR TO HAVE
SCIENTISTS TO FOLLOW SCIENCE. TO
HAVE A PUBLIC HEALTH. EXPERTS AT
THE TABLE AND THIS BILL ALLOWS
US TO DO THIS FOR AIR QUALITY-
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT WE RE IN
A PLACE FOR THIS BILL HAS
OPPOSITION- BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO BE CONSISTENT IN
CALIFORNIA AND SAY WE'VE DONE
THIS FOR OTHER COMMUNITIES- ARE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
DESERVES. WHY ARE STATE HAS
WHAT'S THAT HAKIM VALLEY HAS A
WHAT SAN DIEGO HAS- AND WE
DESERVE. TO DO SO IN A
TRANSPARENT AND CONSISTENT WAY
LIKE WE HAVE ON MULTIPLE ISSUES
IN THE STATE- I DO HOPE THAT AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD WE CAN
FIND A WAY TO CONTINUE- THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH OPPOSITION
BUT ALSO. I KNOW THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO DO FOR THIS
COMMUNITY WHAT THIS BODY HAS
DONE FOR OTHER COMMUNITIES. SO
WITH THAT I HOPE WHAT WE CAN
PASS THIS BILL. THANK YOU CENTER
LIMÓN. CENTER ROTH. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I JUST WANT TO- THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR A LISTENING TO ME
AND TO MY CONCERNS AND THE
CONCERNS OF SOME OF THE
CONSTITUENTS IN THE DISTRICT
THAT I'M- PRIVILEGED TO
REPRESENT AND I APPRECIATE HER
COMMITMENT. TO MAKE THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY WITH
RESPECT TO THE TWO PROPOSED
MEMBERS OF ONE CONVERTING TO A
PUBLIC HEALTH MEMBER AND ANOTHER
TO A SCIENTIST I THINK. THOSE
SIR INDIVIDUALS IN THOSE
OCCUPATIONS AND WITH THOSE
PROFESSIONAL QUALIFICATIONS WILL
ADD A GREAT DEAL OF TO THE
DELIBERATIONS AT THE SOUTH COAST
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY. THANK YOU CENTER
ROTH MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE. SENATE WORK I'M SO SORRY
PLEASE PROCEED THIS MICROPHONES
BLEND IN MAYBE I DON'T KNOW I
PUT IT UP LATE SO I APOLOGIZE
MAN PRESIDENT SO I'M I'M I'M
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BUT I KNOW
THE AUTHOR AGAIN TALKED ABOUT
TRYING TO BRING ALL ALL PARTIES
TOGETHER WHICH I GUESS SHE'S
BEEN DOING I JUST WOULD.
ENCOURAGE HER AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD PARTICULARLY AS IT
RELATES TO JOBS IN IN THE
BUILDING TRADE SAID SHE WOULD
CONTINUE TO GET ENGAGE WITH THEM
AND HOPEFULLY WHEN IT IF IT
COMES BACK THAT I WOULD BE IN A
POSITION. TO SUPPORT IT. THANK
YOU SENATOR WILK MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE CENTER GONZALEZ YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I DEEPLY APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUES- COMMENTS AND REMARKS
IT MEANS A LOT I WOULDN'T BE SO
HARD PRESSED IF WE KNEW WHAT THE
ISSUE REALLY WAS AGAIN THERE ARE
SO MANY KIDS IN THE LOS ANGELES
REGION IS WHAT WHAT I CAN SPEAK
ABOUT- WHERE THEIR MOMS ARE
COMING TO ME EVERY SINGLE DAY
TALKING ABOUT THE ASTHMA THEY'RE
THEY'RE VYING FOR GRANTS FROM
THE PORT OF LONG BEACH TO GET.
FILTERS IN THE SCHOOLS NEXT TO
REFINERIES IN MEAT PROCESSING
PLANTS IT IS A REAL ISSUE AND
AGAIN WE CAN'T DELAY THIS
PROGRESS WHAT I WILL SAY IS
ABSOLUTELY I THINK- MY
COLLEAGUES. FROM LOS ANGELES AS
WELL ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
AISLE WHO HAD MENTIONED MY WORK
WITH- LABOR I HAVE BEEN WORKING
EVERY SINGLE DAY WITH NOT ONLY
THE STATE TRADES BUT THE LOCAL
TRADES TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE ALL
ON THE SAME PAGE I DON'T WANT TO
BRING SOMETHING BACK THAT'S
STILL NOT AMENABLE TO ALL SIDES
BUT WE'VE GOT WORK TO DO. AND SO
I WANT TO THINK AGAIN- THOSE WHO
WILL BE IN SUPPORT TODAY I URGE
MEMBERS ESPECIALLY HERE IN THE
SOUTH COAST AIR BASIN IF YOU CAN
SUPPORT STRUCTURE THAT WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE
WE CANNOT GET ANOTHER LA TIMES
ARTICLE TELLING US THAT WE NEED
TO DO SOME MORE WORK- IN IN AND
NOT ACT ON THIS BILL IF THIS
BILL SHOULD MAKE IT OUT TODAY I
WILL BRING IT BACK THAT IS THE
COMMITMENT THAT I'VE MADE TO MY
COMMUNITY TO ENSURE THAT WE
CLEAN AIR. BUT WE HAVE THE
REPRESENTATION- THAT CAN LEVEL
UP THOSE DISCUSSIONS ON AIR
QUALITY AND WITH THAT I WOULD
APPRECIATE AND ASK FOR AN AND I
AN SB THREE FORTY TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR GONZALEZ.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. OUR I ARCHULETA. AT AYE
BAKER. I FOR JUST NO CABALLERO.
CORTEZ THE- DALLY NO DODD.
DURACELL HI EGGMAN AYE GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROW HERTZBERG. WESO
HER TADO I JONES NO KAMLAGER. I
LAYERED I LEYVA HI THE MON I
REQUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NO MEN.
NEWMAN NIELSEN NO A CHOI BOGUE
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO. ROTH I
RUBIO. SKINNER I STERN AYE
NUMBER. WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER
AYE WILK NOW PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
CABALLERO. CORTESE DODD. GLAZER
GROWTH HERTZBERG. WHERE. HUESO I
. MAN NEWMAN. PORTANTINO RUBIO.
AMBERG SENATOR MOVES THE CALL
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON THE
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX THAT IS
SENATOR BATES SHE WILL BE
PRESENTING REMOTELY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL SIX FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR
BATES AN ACT RELATING TO
DENTISTRY. SENATOR BATES. CAN
YOU HEAR ME NOW WE CAN HEAR YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
S. B. R. SIX FIFTY TWO DEALS
WITH ADULTS. ARE DENTAL SEDATION
WHICH BUILDS ON THE WORK I'VE
DONE WHICH SENATE BILL FIVE OH
ONE BY OUR COLLEAGUES FROM
AROUND OUT IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WHILE WORKING ON THE BILL WE
LEARNED THAT THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL BOARD FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS HAS BEEN UNABLE TO
COMPLETE THE REGULATIONS AND
OPEN LICENSING FOR CHANGES THAT
ARE REQUIRED IN SB FIVE OH ONE.
THOSE CHANGES TOOK EFFECT ON
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
FOR THAT REASON I DID CLICK YES
SB SIX FIFTY TWO ON AN ACTIVE.
WELL I BELIEVE ADDRESSING ADULTS
THE NATION ISSUES. YES AND
PARODIA FOR THE MOMENT IT IS
CLEAR THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE DOWNWARD HAS FULLY
IMPLEMENTED SB FIVE OH ONE. BOTH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ORAL MAXILLOFACIAL SURGEONS AND
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION HAVE ASKED US TO
MOVE THIS BILL TO THE ASSEMBLY
AS. OUR LICENSE REQUIREMENTS
THAT SB FIVE OH ONE REQUIRE IS
SEVENTY EIGHT YES YEAH YES YEAH
SB SIX FIFTY TWO MOVES FORWARD
IN THE ASSEMBLY ALL OF THE
CURRENT CONTENTS WILL BE
STRIPPED AND YOU WILL SEE THE
BILL AGAIN ON CONCURRENCE IN A
DIFFERENT FORM. REMAIN WE REMAIN
HOPEFUL THAT THE DASHBOARD AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS WILL BE ABLE TO DELIVER
ON IMPLEMENTATION OF SB FIVE OR
ONE REGULATIONS BY SPRING
HOWEVER IF ACCESS TO CARE TO
DENTISTRY FOR CHILDREN OUT YES
AT RISK. SB SIX FIFTY TWO CANADA
RUSSELL'S ISSUES IN THE INTERIM
I HAVE COMMITTED TO THE CHAIR OF
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND THE
SENATOR FOR A RANDOM BUT I WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM AND
THE OTHER STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
THE ADMINISTRATION AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD. I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THE YOU
SENATOR PER MAY. ANY DISK OR
DEBATE ON THE BILL BEFORE US.
CENTER GLAZER. AND WORKING YES
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT ON
MEMBERS. IN THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM- IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT I COULD SUPPORT A IF THAT
WAS THE END OF THE STORY TODAY
IT WAS THE- YOU KNOW THE A OR
THE ORIGINS OF THIS ISSUE IS A
VERY UNFORTUNATE EVENTS. OF A
YOUNG CHILD- UNDER SEDATION-
DYING AND- THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NOW SUPERINTENDENT THURMOND. BUT
A BILL FORWARD TO TRY TO ENHANCE
THE SAFETY PROTOCOLS AROUND THIS
TYPE OF A PROCEDURE. I WENT TO A
HEARING IN BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS I DIDN'T HAVE THE
VOTES TO MOVE OUT- IN INTERIM
HEARING WAS HELD ON THE SUBJECT
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT SOME COMMON
GROUND. AND OUT OF THAT- CHAIRED
A BNP CENTER HILL LAST THAT I
TRY TO FIND SOME COMPROMISE IN
THE SUBJECT AREA WHICH IS THE
ORIGINAL BILL THAT'S IN PLACE
TODAY. AT THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM ON THE FLOOR TENDS
TO IT IT IT. IT VANCE THAT
AGREEMENT TO. A MUCH BROADER-
SUBSET OF PATIENTS- BUT DOESN'T
ALLOW FOR THE STUDIES THAT WERE
AGREED TO IN THAT COMPROMISED TO
BE COMPLETED. THE AUTHOR NOW IS
INDICATING THAT. SHE BELIEVES
THAT THE STUDIES DO NEED TO
HAPPEN BEFORE A CHANGE MIGHT BE.
UNNECESSARY AND SHE'S ASKED THAT
SHE BE ALLOWED THE TIME. TO TRY
TO FIND THAT COMMON GROUND IF
IT'S NECESSARY IN THE OTHER
HOUSE. ACCORDINGLY I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. KNOW
THAT YOU'LL HEAR TO HER
COMMITMENT TO- NOT MOVE A CHANGE
UNTIL THE STUDIES HAVE BEEN
COMPLETED. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER
MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
SERVICE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
BELIEVE THANK GOD THE SENATOR
FOR READOUT FOR MAKING IT VERY
CLEAR WHAT OUR INTENTION YOU
KNOW SITE TO ENSURE THAT SB FIVE
OH ONE. NEEDS THE INTENT THAT
ARE WAS PUT FORTH WITH ALL THE
WORK THAT THE SENATOR DID YOU
WANT THAT. FOLLOWING THAT
FORTUNATE SITUATION THE YOUNG
CHILD UNDER SEDATION SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK READ ON BELOW
THANK YOU SENATOR. BATES MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS
AYE BAKER. I FOR JUST I COME BY
OTHER HYPERTENSIVE. I DALLY.
FIVE DOT. THEY'RE AWESOME I
EGGMAN AYE GLAZER. I GONZALEZ
FIVE GROW HERTZBERG I WAS SO. I
HER DAUGHTER AYE JONES. I
KAMLAGER. LAYERED I LEYVA I
LIMON FIVE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ
AYE MIN. I NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN I
A CHOI BOGUE HI CAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
HI SKINNER I STERN AYE I'M BURKE
I LIKE HOW SCHEME I WIENER AYE
WILK AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DODD I. GROVE KAMLAGER
I. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. I MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE BACK IN THE FILE
TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH. ONE WE WILL
START WITH ONE AND ONE MOMENT.
THEREBY.
AN EARLIER THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE'LL START
WITH FILE ITEM ONE CENTER
LAYERED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF THE
LISTED OF ELIZABETH HIDING AS
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISRATIVE LAW SHE HAS SPENT
MANY YEARS WORKING AS AN
ATTORNEY AT THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW SHE'S ALSO
SERVED AS STAFF COUNSEL AT THE
STATE TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM
HE WAS APPROVED IN THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE ON JANUARY
NINETEENTH ON A FOUR TO ZERO
VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIGHTS. THANK YOU CENTER LAYERED
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
. SEEING AND HEARING THEM. BUT
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA. HI
ATKINS AYE BECKE AYE FORGES AYE
COME BY ADAM. I FOR TESTING I
DALY I DODD I TO RUSSELL. EGGMAN
I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. I HER TADO
I JONES HI KAMLAGER I LAYERED HI
LEYVA HI THE MON I MCGUIRE. I
MELENDEZ AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN.
NIELSEN. BUT CHOI BOGUE I CAN I
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH FIVE RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN AYE NUMBER I
LIKE HOW SKI I WIENER AYE WILK
AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. THEY'RE AWESOME I
GROWTH NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN I AT
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED TO BE
ON THE FILE ITEM TO SENATOR
LAYERED. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM TWO IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF VIRGINIA MIGHT
DWINDLE FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
DELTA STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL MISMA
JOIN YOU KNOW IS THE MANAGING
PARTNER OF SAN GUARD L. L. C.
AND CO OWNER AND DIRECTOR OF
MARKETING FOR THE WORLD DESIGN
AND SHOW ROOM IN TURLOCK SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JANUARY NINETEENTH
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE.
THANK YOU CENTER LAYERED MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE BUT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BAKER.
I FOR JUST I COME BY OTHER I FOR
TAXIS. I DALY. DODD I- ALSO I
EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO. JONES HI KAMLAGER I
LAYERED AYE LEYVA AYE THE MON. I
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S AYE MIN
AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. A CHAU
ABODE I PAN I PORTANTINO. HI
ROTH AYE RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
AYE NUMBER. I WHITE HOUSE SKI. I
WIENER AYE WILK AYE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLY I
GROVE HER TADO. NIELSEN I FIVE
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE CENTER LAYERED
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILE
ITEM THREE IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF THE FOLLOWING FOR
APPOINTMENTS TO THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION PATRICK
DAY DR SHANNON GARY DAVID
O'BRIEN AND ON HEALTH RODRIGUEZ
THESE APPOINTMENTS WERE APPROVED
BY THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
JANUARY NINETEENTH ON A FIVE OH
VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU CENTER LAYERED
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
HURSTBRIDGE OF YOUR MICROPHONE
UP. THANK YOU SORRY ABOUT THAT
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE BETTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BAKER. I FORGES I CABALLERO
I PROTESTING AYE DALY I DODD.
TORONTO I EGGMAN I GLAZER. I
GONZALEZ I WROTE HERTZBERG I WAS
SO. I HER TADO I JONES I
KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE LEYVA AYE
LIMON I REQUIRE. I MELENDEZ AYE
MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN AYE A
TO A VOTE AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO
. I ROTH I RUBIO AYE SKINNER. I
STERN AYE NUMBER I LIKE HOUSE
SPEAKER I WIENER. I WILK I THIS
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DODD I
GROVE. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO TAKE A
MOMENT HERE BEFORE WE LEFT CALLS.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
RECESS UNTIL FOUR THIRTY PLEASE
RETURN TO YOUR OFFICES BUT BE
BACK HERE AT FOUR THIRTY WE'LL
SEE YOU AT THAT TIME WE'RE IN
RECESS.
GOOD EVENING MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE
ARE READY TO LIFT CALLS ON THE
BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH. SB FIFTY
THREE FILE ITEM EIGHT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. GROVE MELENDEZ. NUMBER
HI. I THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN MADAM SECRETARY SB SIX
TWENTY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ARCHULETA BACKER
. PORGES CABALLERO. QUARTET
THING. TORONTO GONZALEZ. GROVE
HERTZBERG HER TADO. KAMLAGER
LEYVA. MELENDEZ MEN. NEWMAN PAN
ROTH STERN. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA BAKER
. FOR JUST. CABALLERO CORTESE.
THEY'RE AWESOME. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I GROVE HERTZBERG HER
TADO. KAMLAGER LEYVA. MELENDEZ
MAN. NEWMAN PAM ROTH STERN
PLEASE CALL THE OF THE MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME. ARCHULETA I.
BAKER PORGES CABALLERO QUARTET.
THREE THERE ALSO I. GROWTH
HERTZBERG HER TADO. KAMLAGER
LEYVA I MELENDEZ MEN. NEWMAN PAM
RALPH STERN HI BY TWENTY THREE
KNOWS TO THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN SB THREE FORTY TWO
MEN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
CABALLERO CORTESE. DODD GLAZER
AYE DODD. YEAH DOT. I GLAZER.
GROWTH HERTZBERG. MANY NEWMAN
PORTANTINO. RUBIO NUMBER. FOR
TIGER I TO KNOW PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
CABALLERO. COURTESY GLAZER.
GROVE HERTZBERG. MANY NEWMAN.
PORTANTINO RUBIO NUMBER SENATOR
MOVE THE CALL MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NINE SB TWO
THIRTEEN MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BAKER I
. DODD. GROVE MAN. PAN
PORTANTINO ROCK RUBIO AMBERG. IS
TWENTY ONE KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES. ONE MOMENT
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE THIRTY SECONDS AND
WE WILL LIVE CALLS ON THE LAST
BILL.
RIGHT MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO LIFT CALLS ON FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN SB THREE FORTY TWO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA CABAYE
OTHER. OR TESTING. GLAZER GROVE
HERTZBERG. MAN NEWMAN.
PORTANTINO RUBIO. AMBERG. PLEASE
CALL IF THE MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. ARCHULETA CABALLERO.
CORTEZ THE- GLAZER GROVE
HERTZBERG MANY. NEWMAN
PORTANTINO RUBIO I'M BURKE. IS
NINETEEN KNOWS EIGHT. IS
NINETEEN KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE
FAILS.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SENATOR MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
EIGHT I AM AGAIN MAKING
EMOTIONAL WITHDRAWAL S. C. R.
FIVE FROM THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE EVER BROUGHT TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
A FULL AND VIGOROUS DEBATE IT
HAS BEEN SIX HUNDRED AND NINETY
DAYS NOW SINCE THE GOVERNOR'S
DECLARED STATE OF EMERGENCY FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIVE DAYS SINCE I IT
FIRST INTRODUCED A SIERRA FIVE.
EVERYONE WHO WANTS A VACCINE CAN
OR HAS ALREADY GOTTEN THE
VACCINE THOSE WHO DO NOT WISH TO
GET THE VACCINE CLEARLY NO
AMOUNT OF. COMMERCIALS OR
LITERATURE IS GOING TO CONVINCE
THEM TO DO SO. WE RECENTLY HAD A
FOOTBALL GAME YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD- IN WHICH CENTER MELINDA'S
YES WE WILL VOTE ON THE MOTION
WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT HAVING
SCR FIVE BROUGHT OUT OF
COMMITTEES SO THAT WE CAN DEBATE
KNOWN TO YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
ABOUT ENDING THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER MELENDEZ CENTERFIRE.
KAMALA PRESIDENT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOVA THANK
YOU SAN REQUIRE CENTER JONES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT JUST
WANT TO RISE AND SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF THE MOTION. ARE GOOD CALLING
FROM RIVERSIDE HAS- MULTIPLE
TIMES COME AND DINNER JONES
APPEALED IT'S NOT DEBATABLE YOU
CAN JUST ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
VOTE YES ON OUR AYE ON THE
MEASURE. YES MA'AM PRESENT THANK
YOU I WAS SPEAKING TO THE
MOTION- ENCOURAGING THE BODY TO.
VOTE IN FAVOR OF THE MOTION IN
HONOR OF OUR GOOD CALLING FROM
RIVERSIDE THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER JONES MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN OR-
ALLEN NO ARCHULETA NO ATKINS NO
BAKER. NO FOR JUST. CABALLERO NO
CORTESE. NO DALLY I DON. NO
THEY'RE AWESOME. THERE ARE OTHER
. NO EGGMAN NO GLAZER NO
GONZALEZ NO GROWTH HERTZBERG NO
WAY SO. NO HER TADO. NO JONES HI
KAMLAGER NO LAYERED NO LEYVA NO
LIMON NO MCGUIRE NO MELENDEZ AYE
MAN. NO NEWMAN NO NIELSEN I A
TRAIL OF BOTH I CAN. NO
PORTANTINO NO ROTH. NO RUBIO NO
SKINNER. NO STERN NO NUMBER OKAY
NO WAY HOUSEKI NO WIENER NO WILK
HI BY SIX KNOWS THIRTY THE
MEASURE FAILS MEMBERS IF THERE
IS NO OTHER BUSINESS FEDERAL
REQUIRED THE DESK IS CLEAR THANK
YOU SO MUCH MANY PRESIDENT- WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO EACH AND
EVERY SENATOR FOR ALL OF THEIR
WORK HERE TODAY AT THE SENATE IS
ADJOURNED WE'RE GONNA RECONVENE
THURSDAY AT NINE AM. THANK YOU
CENTER MATHEMATICAL HIGHER THE
SENATE ADJOURNED AND WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE AM
HAVE A GREAT REST THE DAY
MEMBERS.